Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Es ist März, aufregend.
Ja, es ist sehr viel passiert in den letzten Tagen. Wir müssen also über den Iran sprechen unbedingt. Aber zuvor möchte ich etwas korrigieren und ergänzen. Denn ich habe hier mal behauptet vor, ich glaube, zwei Ausgaben und da gab es einige E-Mails dazu, die das korrigiert haben, dass es für russische Studenten, wenn sie in Deutschland studieren, so sein muss, dass sie da ein Sperrkonto haben mit etwa 12.000 Euro drauf, woraufhin man mir sagte, ja, das stimmt. Aber das gilt für alle Nicht-EU-Studenten, die müssen ein solches Sperrkonto haben. Daraufhin habe ich aber noch mal nachgefragt, was ist jetzt die spezifische Problematik bei den russischen Studenten, die hier studieren wollen, die also auch dann nicht in der Heimat sein wollen. Habe also bei der besagten Studentin und ihrem Freund nachgefragt, mit denen ich gesprochen habe und die haben mir eine lange E-Mail geschrieben. Und da bin ich sehr dankbar, denn es ist schon interessant, wie das geregelt ist. Ohne festen Wohnsitz in der EU ist es für russische Staatsangehörige nämlich kaum möglich, ein Konto bei einer Bank in der EU zu eröffnen. Natürlich reichen keine russischen Bankkonten, weil von der EU aus kein Zugriff möglich ist. Das heißt, diese Schwierigkeit haben die schon für alle russischen Studierenden, die ein Bachelor-Studium beginnen wollen und noch nie in Russland studiert haben, ist der Besuch eines Studienkollegs erforderlich. Hierfür ist zudem eine vorherige Aufnahmeprüfung vor Ort in Deutschland zu absolvieren und hierfür ist es schwierig, ein Visum zu erhalten. Drittstaatler außerhalb der EU, also auch Russen, mit kurzem Aufenthalt dürfen nur für wenige Tage ein Visum bekommen, für die Zeit der Prüfung zum Studienkolleg quasi, da ja kein bestehender Prüfung garantiert werden kann. Danach ist eine sofortige Abreise wieder erforderlich. Um ein Sperrkonto zu eröffnen, müssen sie also quasi parallel zur Prüfung eine Wohnung finden, sich bei den Behörden melden, Post bekommen und dann ein Sperrkonto eröffnen. Alles innerhalb von wenigen Tagen. Bei kurzen Visa ist der Kontakt mit der Bundespolizei auch hin und wieder schwierig, steht hier. Grundsätzlich gelten für Russen erschwerte Bedingungen für Visa-Anträge durch Beschluss des Europäischen Rats infolge des Krieges. Mehr dazu auf der Website der Deutschen Botschaft. Dann kommen sie mit einer persönlichen Anekdote, wo jetzt keine Allgemeingültigkeit drin liegen muss, sagen sie. Ein russischer Freund hat die Erfahrung gemacht, dass Zeugnisse aus Russland kaum oder gar nicht anerkannt werden. Es handelte sich um einen fast abgeschlossenen Bachelorabschluss in Pharmazie. Dieser musste daher das Studienkolleg vollständig absolvieren und von vorne anfangen. Grundsätzlich bestehen große Schwierigkeiten mittels Flüge aus Moskau und Russland in die EU einzureisen. Außerdem besteht keine Möglichkeit, Geld aus Russland in die EU zu überweisen, sodass eine finanzielle Unterstützung des Studiums z.B. durch die Familie verunmöglicht wird. Dann noch ein Hinweis allgemein zu dem Sperrkonto. Um überhaupt ein Visum beantragen zu können, muss ein Kontostand von mindestens 11.904 Euro verpflichtend nachgewiesen werden. Monatlich dürfen dann von diesem Konto maximal 992 Euro auf ein, in Anführungszeichen, normales Konto überwiesen werden. Und nach einem Jahr muss allerdings zur Verlängerung des Visums wieder der Kontostand der Alte wieder da sein, 11.904 Euro. Aufgrund der oben angesprochenen erschwerten finanziellen Bedingungen und der ausbleibenden Unterstützung durch Angehörige stellt dies für russische Studierende ein besonderes Problem dar. Einen BAföG-Anspruch haben russische Studierende im Gegensatz zu ukrainischen Studierenden auch nicht. Diejenigen Russen, die es in die EU geschafft haben, bekommen keinen offiziellen Flüchtlingsstatus anerkannt. Ausnahmen bestehen lediglich bei politischen Asylstatus. Die Anerkennungsquote für russische Deserteure und Wehrpflichtige ist hier übrigens sehr gering. Asyl kann natürlich auch nur in Deutschland vor Ort beantragt werden. Zusammengefasst ist es so gut wie unmöglich, als Russe oder Russin in die EU nach 22 einzureisen und anschließend zu studieren. Wir reden ja viel über Manpower, über Fachkräftemangel, darüber, dass Putin auch einen Krieg gegen die Demografie führt, beziehungsweise von vorher her getrieben ist. Wir könnten also Putin erheblich schwächen, wenn ich mir mal dieses Wir anmaßen möchte. Wir werden ja heute noch zu Ricke Hermann kommen, da haben wir ganz viel von diesem Wir. Also es ist ein Wahnsinn, dass man nicht sagt, toll, wir nehmen jetzt die Leute hier ab, und die leben hier ein ganz anderes Leben. Nein, man erschwert es ihnen, man lässt sie dort, damit sie Kanonenfutter bleiben. Die haben dann noch hier angemerkt, noch mal komplizierter wird es dann für Doppelstaatler, denn da gibt es ja Vorschläge im Sondierungspapier von CDU, CSU und SPD, dass man diese doppelte Staatsbürgerschaft bei Russen aufgibt, was dann bedeutet, die müssten sich hier entscheiden, dann müssten also dann die deutsche Staatsbürgerschaft annehmen. Jetzt kann man sagen, ja, ist doch gut, warum die wollen doch eh nicht in Russland sein. Das bedeutet für die dann aber auch eine Gängelung seitens Russlands, beziehungsweise für einige wird es so aussehen, dass sie dann keine Chance mehr haben, in Russland mal wieder ihre Familie zu sehen. Wenn sie diesen Pass aufgegeben haben, den russischen, dann ist das ein klares Statement für Russland. Und ich habe auch eine Anekdote, die ich jetzt nicht hier weiter erzählen will. Aus dem Konsulat gehört, wie da dann umgegangen wird mit den Doppelstaatlern, die eher nach Deutschland tedieren als nach Russland. Insofern ist das eine Situation, die eigentlich untragbar ist. Und würde man den Menschen helfen, würde man jedenfalls Putin auch schaden.
Ja, das ist natürlich, ich würde auch sagen, der Brain Drain ist ja das, was Putin am meisten fürchtet. Und das, was wir offenbar am meisten ihm noch zugestehen. Die Leute dürfen nicht hierher. Und die Frage ist ja, wollen wir nicht, dass die klugen Leute, die ein Land tragen können, mit dem man einen Start machen kann, hierherkommen? Und jetzt hast du den Umgang mit Russen erzählt. Hier in Hessen, ich hatte ja mich mehrfach jetzt schon darüber beklagt, dass das hessische Bildungskultusministerium gesagt hat, 70 Millionen müssen an den hessischen Schulen gestrichen werden. Also alle außer Gymnasien natürlich. Was bedeutet, es wird wieder so eine kalkulierte Verdummung stattfinden. Nun hat das SPD-Wirtschaftsministerium angeboten, diesen Betrag auszugleichen, also einfach von einem Ministerium zum nächsten zu überweisen, hat natürlich eine Koalitionskrise ausgelöst. Boris Rhein hat sich am Ende durchgesetzt, die Koalition bleibt bestehen, aber dieses Geld fließt nicht. Also nicht nur halten wir kluge Russen raus, sondern wir wollen auch keine klugen Deutschen. Es sind wirklich harte Umstände. Von daher hier ein kleiner Nachtrag. Ich habe jetzt in der Februar-Folge, weil sie so voll war, ganz meine Männer und Frauen des Monats vergessen. Das sind natürlich all diese Kommunalpolitiker in Verantwortung, die unter diesen schweren Umständen von Land und Bund einfach komplett veralbert zu werden, und trotzdem Stadt regieren. Um es mal so drastisch zu sagen. Also es gibt einen Krieg, der brach los, nachdem wir den Podcast gerade vollendet und hochgeladen hatten, weshalb uns einige schrieben, hättet ihr noch einen Tag gewartet, hättet ihr das mitbehandeln können? Und mein erster Gedanke war so, na was hätten wir denn am Tag eins dazu sagen können, außer das übliche wie auch immer. Wir interessieren uns für die Weltlage, aber wir richten uns ja nicht in unserem Rhythmus nach ihr. Stellt sich raus, mein Gedanke war nicht so ganz richtig oder nicht ganz plausibel, denn mittlerweile ist es alles so platt, dass man tatsächlich fünf Stunden, nachdem man sich die Nachrichtenlage angeschaut hat, einfach wirklich ein Fazit ziehen kann. Es ist wirklich alles ganz einfach gestrickt und ich möchte daran erinnern, bevor wir drei Clips zum Iran spielen aus The Daily, um uns das einfach nur zu verdeutlichen, wie das in Venezuela war. Denn das geschah ja auch so am Monatsanfang, sodass wir am Monatsende gar nicht so richtig dazu kamen. Also habe ich nochmal meine Notizen rausgekramt. Am 3. Januar gab es diese Militäroperation Nightfall. Also, die fliegen da rüber, haben das vorher sondiert, geprobt an Nachbauten von dem Haus, wie auch immer, und haben dann Manduru entführt. Dann gab es diese Machtübernahme durch Rodriguez, die Vizepräsidentin. Während hier in Deutschland noch Kommentare geschrieben wurden zum Thema, das ist voll gut, dass der Manduru weg ist, denn das war ein ganz schwieriger Typ und wir sind auch gegen schwierige Typen.
Und jetzt kommt Demokratie da.
Genau. Man mag ja über Trump sagen, was man will, aber er hat zumindest da mal aufgeräumt.
Ja. Übrigens ja von den Leuten, also man muss das sich wirklich ansehen. Also diese Ecke Strack, Zimmermann und Co., die ist ja gerade auf so einem Trip. Wir müssen eigentlich uns sehr emanzipieren. Wir starken Europäer und all das. Und dann sagen sie aber, sobald dann doch irgendetwas geschieht, was Trump macht, was sie wieder gut finden. Ja, nee, da ist er ja noch auf der richtigen Seite. Wir haben zum Teil Leute, die sagen, Trump ist ein Protofaschist oder ein Faschist. Und sie sagen zugleich, wie gut, dass jetzt Trump das autoritäre Regime in Iran absetzt, damit dort Demokratie stattfinden kann. Wir sehen einen Präsidenten und wir sehen ja auch noch einen anderen Präsidenten. Wir sehen Netanyahu, die beide die Demokratie bekämpfen, wo sie nur können. Und zugleich sagen diese Leute, wie gut, dass Netanyahu und Trump Demokratie in die Welt bringen. Vor allem jetzt im Iran.
Genau, und all diese Kommentatoren wurden wirklich hart Lügen gestraft. Denn sie wussten es eigentlich auch besser und es hat sich ja dann in wenigen Tagen entfaltet. Denn es gab dieses Ultimatum der US-Regierung, die maximale Kontrolle wird jetzt über Venezuela. Wir regieren hier wie auch immer, es sei denn, irgendwas begibt sich in Venezuela. Und das hat ja die Machado, die Nobelpreisträgerin, zum Anlass genommen, zu sagen, ich fahre jetzt dahin und guck mal, wie meine Chancen sind. Denn bei so einer großen Wetterlage, wenn in westlichen Zeitungen steht, die mich gerade zu Gast hatten, weil ich aber hier den Nobelpreis in Europa angenommen, dass hier vielleicht Unterstützung für alternative Regime da sind, dann nutze ich diese Chance. Und sie ist natürlich dort einfach keinen Meter vorwärts gekommen. Stattdessen wurde die Rodriguez vereidigt und dann gab es genau einen Tag lang Stress mit Trump über öffentliche Meinungsbekundungen, die von der ich sage, abgesprochen wie zwischen DGB und SPD, wenn irgendeine Sache passiert. Und dann gab es dieses Treffen im Weißen Haus am 15. Januar, bei dem sie ihren Nobelpreis übergibt. Also durch die nachrichtliche Großwetterlage Europa, westliche Welt, zum Glück ist der Maduro weg, zum Glück jetzt Regime Change, der Bevölkerung, dort geht es ganz schlecht. Hat sie gedacht, sie nutzt jetzt die Chance und hat die dümmste Aktion des Jahrhunderts gemacht, nämlich ihren Nobelpreis an ein Handlanger des Regimes, an den Schirmherren, den neuen Schirmherren des Regimes zu schenken. So, und im Zuge dieser Sache hören wir jetzt diese drei Iran-Clips, die New York Times, und das ist eben, deswegen schieben wir es jetzt und am Monatsende mal gucken, was vom Thema übrig bleibt. Aber es war tatsächlich einfach am Tag eins klar, die New York Times hat es so deutlich gemacht mittlerweile, dass man sich auch, da würde ich jetzt wieder sagen, also Trump ist ja wirklich ein ganz fieser, schlechter Mensch und ein schlechter Präsident. Aber dass er den Journalismus wieder dazu führt, seine eigentliche Aufgabe war zu leben, ist voll gut. Also solche Leitartikel würde ich jetzt schreiben.
Nur leider hier nicht so stark.
Leider hier nicht so stark, aber in Amerika ein bisschen anders.
Die New York Times mit einer linksliberalen Zeitung zu tun, die jetzt an sich.
Da werden aber einige jetzt eine linksliberale Zeitung. Also liberal, ja. Die New York Times ist aber nicht.
Na ja, also mit linksliberal meine ich jetzt so Mitte, Mitte, Mitte, links. Also nicht links, so wie ich jetzt links verstehe.
Die New York Times publiziert zu jedem gängigen Suchbegriff, den man gerade in Nachrichtenlage hat, pro Stunde fünf Artikel. Du kannst auch eine ganz andere New York Times lesen.
Ist mir völlig egal, was ich nur damit sagen will. Das ist keine radikal linke Zeitung.
Ach so, genau, ja, genau, keine radikal linke Zeitung.
Das ist nicht Jacobin. Das sind nicht Anti-Imperialisten. Das sind sehr patriotische Autoren aus einer linken, verfassungsdemokratischen Auffassung heraus. Da gibt es auch konservative Stimme. Ich weiß das alles. Was ich nur sagen will, wir sind hier im Mainstream. Wenn wir jetzt in den deutschen Mainstream blicken, dann hören wir genau diese Töne. Ich kenne die Töne noch nicht, aber ich würde jetzt schon mal prognostizieren, die hören wir hier nicht. Und das ist das Verrückte. Hier musst du zu Jacobin etc. gehen, musst du bei Neue Deutschland noch mal nachlesen. Und hier haben wir im Mainstream der amerikanischen Newsfabrik genau die Äußerungen, die wir hier ja vergeblich irgendwo im Mainstream suchen.
Genau, hier muss man eh noch mal eine neue Distinktion einführen irgendwie. Es gibt den Mainstream und dann gibt es so den Mainstream. Aber es ist nicht so der innere Mainstream, sondern es ist der Mainstream der Masse. Und dann gibt es den Mainstream der wenigen, aber die wenigen Tonangebenden.
Ja.
Also da, wo Morgenlagen bereitet werden, wo man noch eine Zeitung liest und so und sich nicht nur beschallen lässt. Genau, wir sind jetzt in diesem innere Minority Mainstream sozusagen, der aber über langes, also im Mittel bis langfristigen Ton eingebend ist, aber nicht im Tagesaktuellen, sondern da ist so Fox News und der ganze Kram. Und da hören wir diese drei Clips. Zum einen, das finde ich jetzt nur inhaltlich auch sehr interessant. Was ist mit Khamenei? Warum hat er sich einfach totschießen lassen? Und es ist genau so von mir jetzt gefragt.
Und was viele iranische Offiziere jetzt sagen, ist, dass Mr. Khamenei sich auf die Hürde seiner Heimat und seiner Kampagne und hat den Leuten um ihn eingeführt, dass, wenn er sich in den Krieg startet, er eher ein Widerstander werden würde. Ich denke, dass in seinem Geist, sein Legatum besser geschützt werden würde, wenn er als jemand gesehen wäre, der nicht in den Händen war, der nicht Angst hatte, wenn er das Geist der Venezuelas, Nicolas Maduro, hätte, Oder wenn sein Regime aufgehoben werden würde, dann wäre er humiliatet.
Hat er sich einfach aufgegeben? 86 Jahre, fast 50 Jahre an der Macht? Hat er gesagt, es reicht?
Es gab von El Hotso so ein Tweet, der hätte ja eh nur noch ein, zwei Jahre gelebt, so ich paraphrasiere jetzt. Und jetzt haben die dem noch das Geschenk gemacht, dass er Märtyrer werden kann. Und jetzt hören wir das im Prinzip hier.
Es ist ein ganz ernsthafter Gedanke.
Na ja, gut, das ist nur ein fanatischer Mensch, wie wir wussten und wissen. Und dann leuchtet das sehr ein.
Aber es ist wirklich erstaunlich, im Zuge einer Diskussion, in der wir Milliardäre auch nachher wieder nur unter Longevity, ewig, maximale Macht und so weiter diskutieren.
Na ja, die sind ja, wenn sie zum Himmel blicken, da ist dann nicht viel. Aber diese traditionell fanatischen Gläubigen, die sagen dann, na ja, da wird ja schon auf mich gewartet.
Also das ist wirklich, das fand ich wahnsinnig interessant. So und jetzt die beiden Clips, also wir haben es ausreichend vorbereitet.
Wir wundern uns ja sowieso, dass die Iran angegriffen wird, weil wir doch vor ein paar Monaten schon mal diese Angriff hatten und dann hatte doch Trump uns gesagt, dass alles zerstört wurde und zwar auf Jahrzehnte, soweit ich mich recht erinnere.
Das hat man natürlich im Fernsehpodcast Juxens zur Geltung gebracht, wie das thematisiert wurde. Aber genau, es sollte doch alles obliviated sein. Nun, während die deutschen Kommentatoren ihre Texte noch nicht mal angefangen haben zu schreiben, wie schlimm das im Iran ist und zum Glück ist das Regime weg, New York Times.
Ist es, Farnas, ein Leader im Regime, den USA, den Israel, eine Toleranz finden kann, die sie als jemanden sehen, der in Theorie zufrieden sein könnte, was von dem Regime bleibt, die Leidenschaften, die möglicherweise zu der Opposition sind, und die USA, Israel und ihre Leaders können damit etwas tun.
Das ist die Art von Person, die die USA in Venezuela gefunden hat, nachdem es Nicolás Maduro verletzt hat.
Es ist interessant, dass du Venezuela heranbringst, weil iranische Gründer mir sagen, dass eine der Gespräche, die sie in private haben, über die Succession und über das Planen, zwischen sich selbst ist die Frage, wer der Delsi von Iran sein wird, das mit dem Vizepräsidenten von Venezuela zu sprechen. Einige der Namen, die hierherkommen sind, sind Technikraten und Ex-General der Revolutionärgärten, die als Zentristen, Pragmatisten, Menschen sind, die vielleicht offen sind für eine Veränderung. Einige der Namen sind Ali Laridani, der Chef des Nationalen Sicherheitskanzels, der jetzt effektiv das Land runnend ist.
Regime-Change?
Ganz normale Politik. Die rufen quasi an und fragen, wer aus der Nationalgarde kann denn jetzt hier? Und es ist tatsächlich Chefsache, ja. Also Trump selbst ist es ein Anliegen.
Das sind einige der Namen, die ich gehört habe. Aber ich möchte hier erwähnen, dass für diesen 80 Prozent. Ich glaube, die USA und Präsident Trump werden letztendlich entscheiden, dass er keine Risiken für die Stabilität in Iran will, er keine Risiken für eine zivilische Kriegung will und eher mit jemanden von diesem System engagieren würde, der sich bereit sein würde, Konzessionen zu machen oder nicht. Genau. Wir haben heute von Präsident Trump gehört, dass er offen ist, mit den neuen Leadern von Iran zu sprechen und dass er gehört hat, dass es ein paar Optionen gibt für die Succession.
So dreht sich das Autokratenkarussell weiter. Da geht es nicht um die Befreiung der Bevölkerung. Es war ja sowieso lustig, dass Trump dann sowas sagte, wie und jetzt muss das iranische Volk aufstehen, aber bleiben sie bitte zu Hause, damit sie nicht von den Bomben getroffen werden. Also das funktioniert natürlich alles vorne und hinten nicht, dass man uns das hier immer noch einredet und auch Leute bereit sind, das zu glauben. Was muss denn Trump noch machen, dass man dann davon mal abrückt? Ich verstehe das gar nicht. Wie ist das möglich? Also wenn das jetzt der wohlmeinende Präsident wäre von früher, der das freundliche Gesicht gezeigt hätte und das noch bemäntelt hätte, dann würde ich sagen, naja, da sind manche zu naiv. Oder wir haben natürlich auch viele Leute, die es glauben wollen. Aber das hier ist ja nun jetzt so offenbar, dass man auch sagen muss, wer da das Gegenteil behauptet, lügt. Anders ist es überhaupt nicht auszudrücken.
Also die Zeit hatte, ich habe mir extra einen Screenshot gemacht, weil es ungewöhnlich war, einen Aufmacher als Kommentar auf die Seite genommen. Dieser Angriff ist ein großes Unrecht für den Krieg gegen den Iran. Hat Donald Trump keine Gründe und keinen Plan, die folgen wird, Europa spüren? Umso fataler, wie sich die Bundesregierung weggduckt.
Ja.
Es war wirklich der einzige Text, der mal in die Richtung geht. Ich habe den jetzt komplett nicht gelesen, sondern mir nur den Skizchat gemacht am Morgen.
In unseren Mainstream-Podcast, die wir jetzt nicht alle hier wieder erwähnen, eigentlich nur Propaganda für diese Sache. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man das rechtfertigen kann, wie das möglich ist, dass man auch glaubt, dass man nach wie vor diese Erzählweise fortsetzen kann, wo ich auch sagen muss, so doof ist ja wirklich niemand, das noch zu glauben.
Eigentlich nicht. Es ist wirklich verrückt. Ich möchte einen soziologischen Hinweis, weil wir ja immer die Frage hatten, wie stabilisiert man überhaupt so eine Diktatur? Da steht einer an der Spitze wie Putin oder so und das ganze Land gehorcht. Wie funktioniert das? Und dann hören wir immer den Standard, ja Medien ausschalten, Gerichte auf Kurs bringen, wie wir es in Polen gesehen haben. Also das droht sozusagen überall. Aber die Frage ist ja wirklich konkret, wie gelingt es? Und im Iran ist es ganz offensichtlich und für alle sichtbar beantwortet, diese Frage. Und das haben wir auch zuletzt durch diese Massaker gesehen. Denn es ist nicht schon lange nicht mehr zentral gesteuert, dieses religiös irgendwie aufgeputschte Regime von alten Leuten, die irgendwas wollen. Also die schaffen es nicht, 40.000 Leute totzuschießen, sondern das Prinzip läuft über diese Nationalgarde, die das Land längst regiert oder sich aufgeteilt hat, wie so eine Mafia auf jeder Straße ein Profitinteresse einfach manifestiert.
Wie in Indien. Ich will jetzt nicht Indien mit dem Iran vergleichen, aber in Indien sehen wir auch, wie solche paramilitärischen Strukturen von Modi immer weiter aufgebaut wurden, die ihm erst den Erfolg gesichert haben. Und dann haben die irgendwann eine eigene unternehmerische Tätigkeit im Land und sorgen dafür, dass alle auf Spur bleiben und haben unglaubliche Spielräume, sich selbst zu ermächtigen und zu handeln und brutal Aufstände oder Dissidenz niederzuschlagen.
So, und das bedeutet aber, wir haben es hier mit 10.000, 100.000 involvierten Menschen zu tun, bewaffnet, die alle, also die haben einen ordentlichen Rekrutierungsapparat. Da kannst du jetzt nicht einfach in Tehran jemanden wegschießen und dann 200 Kilometer weit entfernen, sagt dann jemand, oh ja, okay, dann machen wir jetzt Demokratie oder so. Sondern die kämpfen jetzt alle für sich um diese Vorherrschaft. Von daher ist dieses Regime-Change anliegend sowieso und von jemandem wie Donald Trump, der seinen Truppen noch, und das ist auch eine interessante Parallele, angeblich wurde ja den Militärs jetzt gesagt, hier geht es um Armageddon, also die Ermöglichung der Wiederkunft Christi. Wir haben das ja ausführlich thematisiert, wo diese Ideen herkommen und wie die auch in deutschen Podcasts so thematisiert werden. Und langsam stellt sich auch die Frage, ich hatte es ja bei Venezuela schon kurz aufgeworfen, warum fand denn für den Irak-Krieg so ein großes mediales, die UN, Colin Powell, erzählt da irgendwas von Massenvernichtungswaffen. Wir haben immer gedacht, das ist für uns, für die öffentliche Meinung. Nein, das ist damit die Soldaten, die konkret schießen, zu Hause sagen können, ich habe es für die Demokratie getan. So, zum zweiten Mal jetzt innerhalb eines Jahres müssen diese Soldaten zu Hause sich anders rechtfertigen, weil sie dieses Angebot nicht mehr haben. Beim ersten Mal hat Trump selber gesagt, mir geht es hier ums Öl. Was bedeutet, wenn man zu Weihnachten als Soldat nach Hause kehrt, ist es, ah, du hast hier fürs Öl den Weg freigeschossen, ne, für die Demokratie. Das habe ich aber anders gehört bei meinem Präsidenten. Und warum ist das Öl jetzt gerade so teuer?
Naja, das war, weil wir da auch im Iran waren, da war wieder anders.
Genau, und wenn jetzt im Iran plötzlich die Soldaten sich eben eins zu eins, im privaten eins zu eins, plötzlich mit Armageddon und Jesus Christ rumschlagen müssen, also das ist einfach, also hier lodert noch eine ganz andere Sache vor sich. Dazu werden wir keinen deutschen Text bekommen. Wir haben häufiger die Frage, warum wir so, gerade ich so viel New York Times lese, weil da halt sowas thematisiert wird. Aber in den Deutschen einfach gar nicht, nirgendwo. Also ich wüsste jetzt keine Zeitung.
Ich hab dir jetzt einen Clip mitgebracht, Stefan. Wir haben natürlich auch unsere News. Ich hab gedacht, ich bin ja ein einfacher Mensch, lass es mir doch mal wie für ein Kind erklären, hab mir das ZDF-Logo angesehen. Dort war Armin Laschet im Interview und dem wurden Fragen gestellt von jungen Zuschauern, die wissen wollten, wie geht es denn da jetzt weiter. Wir haben jetzt ja in der vergangenen Folge ausführlich über das Social-Media-Verbot geredet und wir wissen, eine Argumentation seitens der Politik ist, die jungen Leute geraten im Netz an Fake-News und die müssen sich richtig informieren können, Medienkompetenz. Deswegen ist das besser, wenn sie dann nicht einfach so irgendwo hineingeraten. Deswegen habe ich gedacht, dann informieren wir uns doch ganz richtig, quasi hochoffiziell ZDF und Armin Laschet. Wir hören da mal rein.
Wissen, wie lange der Krieg voraussichtlich noch dauert und ob es Gründe gibt, warum sich der Krieg noch quasi in die Länge ziehen könnte?
Das kann im Moment gar niemand sagen, wie lange der Krieg dauern wird. Die Schätzungen der Amerikaner waren in den letzten Tagen vielleicht vier Wochen, aber vielleicht geht es auch schneller. Keiner kann das im Moment sagen. Wir müssen uns alle wünschen, dass der Krieg schnell zu Ende geht, so schnell wie möglich und dass die Menschen im Iran dann selbst bestimmen können, wer sie regiert, dass sie eine Demokratie werden, wo auch die jungen Leute eine Chance haben.
Die jungen Leute. Darum geht es eigentlich, die Demokratie. So wird hier informiert. Noch eine Frage an Armin Laschet. Herr Laschet zum Schluss. Das ist übrigens der Moderator von ZDF Logo, der auch diese herrliche Sendung machte, in der Kinder gefragt wurden, willst du zu Militär? Ja oder ja? Wir hatten diese Sache. Jetzt noch der kurze Blick nach vorne. Pauline hat uns folgende Frage zugeschickt. Gibt es schon Ideen, Frieden zu schließen?
Das kann man im Moment noch nicht sagen. Es gibt Ideen, was passiert, wenn der Krieg zu Ende ist. Dann soll der Iran wieder aufgebaut werden. Dann sollen alle die, die im Moment unterdrückt sind, ein neues, freies Land aufbauen.
Wo gibt es diese Idee? Also ich habe sogar noch eine andere Idee gesehen. Da stand Strackzimmermann mit Reza Pahlavi da und wollte uns auch noch signalisieren, vielleicht ist das auch eine Option. Also geht es doch ohne Demokratie.
Ich würde sagen, das korrespondiert ganz wunderbar. Mit diesen 70 Millionen raus aus den Schulen.
Ja. Wo jeder auch nach seiner Vorstellung leben kann. Aber wie jetzt man zu einem Frieden kommt, das kann man jetzt, nachdem zwei Tage erst der Krieg begonnen hat, noch nicht sagen. Das Ziel muss jedenfalls sein, so schnell wie möglich. Und das Ergebnis muss auch sein, der Iran darf keine Atombomben mehr bauen können, denn das bedroht uns und das bedroht auch viele andere.
Herr Laschet, vielen Dank für das Gespräch. Das sieht schon hetslich aus. Ja, also da sagen ja nun jetzt auch hier gestandene Experten, dass mit den Atombomben dabei jetzt nichts in absehbarer Zeit zu befürchten. Es ist unglaublich. Deswegen brauchen wir unbedingt eine Debatte. Brauchen wir ein ZDF-Logo-Verbot? Wie schützen wir unsere Kinder vor ZDF-Logo? Braucht man da vielleicht eine Altersverifikation? Das sollte man dringend jetzt mal starten, diese Debatte. Völkerrecht ist ja so eine Angelegenheit, auf die man sich gerne beruht, bezieht, wenn es einem hilft. Wir haben das gesehen. Wir sehen Völkerrechtsbrüche bei Putin. Deshalb gibt es diese entsprechenden Reaktionen aus dem Westen. Wir sehen aber jetzt gerade die, die besonders auf das Völkerrecht beharrt haben, wie Roderich Kiesewetter und andere, die sagen, naja gut, hier ist das ja ein anderer Fall, weil es ja gar keine Demokratie ist. Aber das Völkerrecht gilt ja auch dann. Es ist eben nicht ein Völkerrecht, das interveniert, wo immer, keine Demokratie ist. Weil dann könnte man permanent intervenieren. Und das ist natürlich eine Frage, ist dann von der Perspektive. Und dann sagt, natürlich aus einer Putin-Perspektive heraus, Putin, ja, wieso soll ich mich denn als Völkerrecht halten? Ihr tut es ja sowieso auch nicht, wie wir hier sehen können. Aber man sieht, mal ist das Völkerrecht sinnvoll, mal ist es nicht sinnvoll. Es gibt aber auch noch Stimmen in Europa, die tatsächlich sich auf das Völkerrecht beziehen und auch klare Kante da machen gegenüber Trump, beziehungsweise auch sich ja scheuen, diese EU-Aufrüstungsstrategien mitzugehen. Wir wissen, Spanien stellt sich da quer. Die sagen, dass sie dieses 3,5 Prozent Ziel NATO nicht erreichen wollen. Sie haben andere Aufgaben, um die sie sich kümmern müssen, zum Beispiel auch Bildung. Da wird nicht irgendwas gespart. Und wir hören uns jetzt mal den Ministerpräsidenten von Spanien an, Pedro Sanchez. Wir hören ihn jetzt mal im Original, weil ich zu gerne Spanisch höre. Aber dann hören wir die Übersetzung. Nein, aber ich finde, das klingt immer so schön.
Gestern, glaube ich, haben diese Angst wieder festgestellt, leider.
Zwei Länder haben unilaterale Attacken auf Iran.
Es gibt immer Platz für eine solch negativen Lösung, statt sich zu lassen, durch die Zerstörung der Waffen als einzige mögliche Ausstieg zu machen. Er sagte hier, wir stehen vor einer sehr gefährlichen Ära. Die Welt wird instabiler, unsicherer, schneller und damit für die Normalbürger ungerechter. Gestern haben sich diese Befürchtungen meiner Meinung nach leider erneut bestätigt. Zwei Länder, die Vereinigten Staaten und Israel, haben den Iran einseitig angegriffen, ohne die internationale Gemeinschaft einzubeziehen. Man kann gegen ein verabscheuungswürdiges Regime sein, wie es die gesamte spanische Gesellschaft gegenüber dem iranischen Regime ist und gleichzeitig gegen eine ungerechtfertigte, gefährliche und völkerrechtswidrige militärische Intervention sein. Man kann gegen einen Krieg sein, der ohne die Zustimmung des US-Kongresses und des UN-Sicherheitsrates begonnen wurde und, wie ich bereits sagte, gegen das Völkerrecht verstößt. Und es gibt immer Raum für eine Verhandlungslösung, anstatt sich von der Zerstörung durch Waffen als einzigem Ausweg mitreißen zu lassen. Das sind kluge Worte. Es ist skandalös.
Können wir uns als Spanisch lesen lassen?
Wie?
Naja, immer wieder revitalisieren, diese Idee, dass man seine Identität so ein bisschen selbst gestaltet.
Ja.
Und ich möchte mich gerne, es ist ja nicht das erste Mal, dass wir aus Spanien jetzt Sachen hören. Plötzlich werden eine halbe Million nicht Spanier ein-europäisiert. Man wendet sich gegen das 5% NATO-Ziel.
Man wendet sich auch gegen diese Austeritätspolitik. Man hat investiert während dieser Krise, während hier alles dümpelte.
Ich wäre gerne in Spanien.
Ich auch, ich habe ja sehr unter diesem Winter gelitten. Das war ja doch wirklich schrecklich. Und Spanien wäre da doch eine Möglichkeit. Ich denke, wir sollten das mal erproben. Vielleicht machen wir... ach so. Ja, ja Moment. Dann könnten wir zumindest nach Gran Canaria. Denn da ist ja immer angenehm.
Barcelona wird auch angenehm.
Vielleicht machen wir es wie bei Wetten Das. Da gab es doch auch immer so eine Sommerausgabe. Dann müssten wir das mal schauen.
Genau. Sommersalor in Barcelona.
Irgendwie sowas.
Ja, das wäre nicht gut.
Wir denken mal darüber nach. Jedenfalls, das sind genau die richtigen Worte. Und ich finde das skandalös, dass Merz sich nicht hinter Petros Anschluss gestellt hat. Dass der dann im Weißen Haus sitzt und quasi Anschluss in den Rücken fällt. Weil Trump da so ein bisschen freiträgt. Da muss man schon auch sehen, wenn man dort sitzt, dann vertritt man Europa und dann muss man gerade hier das sehr ernst nehmen, wenn da ein großes und auch wichtiges Land wie Spanien sich völlig korrekt äußert. Das ist ja nicht irgendwas verrücktes, sondern völlig korrekt geäußert.
Macron hat sich ein bisschen ähnlich geäußert. Und Hans Hüt, dessen Meinung ich ja sehr schätze und der auch sehr viel Erfahrung in Kommentierung von solchen Sachen hat, meinte, das wird Merz und Macron endgültig zerrücken. Und ich denke mir, das wird stimmen. Und Macron steht aber auf der richtigen Seite.
Ich bin gespannt, wie es weitergeht. Wir haben ja jetzt einen Salon vor uns, der zwei geteilt ist zum ersten Mal. Das liegt daran, dass wir über das Buch von Ulrike Herrmann, zwei jetzt gleich auch, sprechen. Wir nehmen da etwas auf, aber wir können das erst in einer Woche veröffentlichen zum Book Release. Also wir sprechen über Geld als Waffe. Das ist das lange erwartete Buch, jedenfalls für viele. Und darüber müssen wir diskutieren. Also sie spricht über Kriegswirtschaft, über das, was für Aufrüstung getan werden muss. Sie beschäftigt sich stark mit China und Russland und unserer Rolle in diesem Spiel. Und wir haben aber noch ein zweites Buch, über das wir im Salon sprechen. Und das veröffentlichen wir jetzt schon. Wir haben uns etwas zweites ausgesucht. Auf deinen Wunsch, muss ich sagen. Ich hatte ja nur die Clips mitgebracht aus dem Ben Podcast mit Bibis, Bianca Heinicke. Und du hattest gesagt, das wäre doch eigentlich ein Buch, über das wir sprechen können.
Ich dachte, sie redet ja nur Blödsinn. Und typischerweise sind ja die Leute im nicht spontanen Gespräch, sondern in der Bücherpublikation etwas klüger. Das wollte ich einfach kurz überprüfen.
Ja, ich habe das auch überprüft. Aber ich bin mir nicht so sicher, ob die Eingangsthese stimmt. Wie man Geschichte schreibt, denn dein Leben verändert die Welt. So heißt dieses Buch. Ich habe es tatsächlich sehr schnell, aber ich habe es durchgelesen. Du bist da nochmal anders rangegangen. Das wirst du uns gleich erzählen. Ich habe tatsächlich bei der Lektüre gedacht, eigentlich wäre es ideal, wir machen ein Bühnenprogramm draus und reisen damit durch die Lande, lesen das in verteilten Rollen. Ich glaube, das wäre Comedy Gold. Aber wir fangen jetzt erst mal damit an, dass wir über dieses Buch reden. Und vielleicht gibt es ja auch das eine oder andere Learning für unser Publikum. Ich bin sehr gespannt. Jedenfalls sehen wir jetzt eine neue Personality oder eine alte Personality möglicherweise. Und da ist gar nicht so viel Neues da. Also wir erforschen das Ich von Bibis und von uns selbst sicherlich auch. Auch mal Konsumkritik.
Fast Kapitalismuskritik, nur Konsumkritik. Folgender Teaser. Wolfgang hat ja ein sehr kritisches Buch geschrieben über Influencer. Und das ist auch ein sehr kritisches Buch. Vielleicht passt es doch besser und dann muss man hintenrum aber sich doch am Kopf kratzen und so ein bisschen.
Vielleicht kann man auch mit den Verlagen reden, dass man es zusammen rausgibt als Paket. Könnte man, wir denken da nah. Da gibt es noch viele Möglichkeiten. Was habe ich noch dabei? Ich habe einmal noch ein Update zu den indischen Studenten in Deutschland. Denen wurde ja schon das Leben schwer gemacht. Jetzt sollen sie sogar noch ausreisen, hunderte von ihnen, ehe sie einen Studienabschluss haben. Wir sprechen kurz über einen Artikel aus dem Telegraph über die Situation in der iranischen Zivilbevölkerung. Ich habe ein grandioses neues Klassikalbum dabei. Mein Lieblings-Streichquartett Leonkoro hat geliefert, endlich eine neue CD. Dann werfen wir einen psychoanalytischen Blick auf unsere Gegenwart. Also was leugnen wir und was verleugnen wir? Wie müssen wir Trump nochmal anders sehen? Was genießen wir eigentlich, wenn wir Trump sehen? Auch da geht es zum Beispiel um Trump bei der Kirk-Trauerfeier. Was passiert da eigentlich, wenn er sagt, aber sorry, ich hasse meine Gegner? Und er das ganz klar ausbringt. Alenka Zupančič aus dem Slawoj-Šiček-Umfeld. Nein, dachte mir schon. Ja, du hast es dir gedacht. Sie legt hier ein Buch vor, das heißt Das Ende, mit einzelnen Texten, die ja vom Ende handeln. Vom Ende oder von den Enden, muss man sagen. Und ich habe den Debüt-Roman gelesen von Hiroko Oyamada. Da hatten wir schon mal das Buch von ihr, Das Loch. Und jetzt kommt heraus Die Fabrik.
Sehr gut. Ich ergänze mit Carla Hinrichs. Das Buch ist da. Sie ist angeklagt wegen Rädelsführerin einer kriminellen Vereinigung. Hier werden also Jahrhunderte alte Terrorparagrafen wieder angewandt. Das müssen wir uns mal anschauen. Außerseben habe ich sie ja vor zwei Jahren in meinem Fernsehpodcast, habe ich den Fernseh, oder den, wie nenne ich es? Fernsehmoment des Jahres ausgewählt, weil sie bei Anne Will saß und dort die Frage aufkam, aber Frau Hinrichs, können Sie nicht ein bisschen konstruktiver Kampagne machen und protestieren? Und dann fragte sie nur zurück, haben Sie eine Idee? Und Anne Will so, ich? Nein. Also wirklich grandios. Und das wird auch ausführlich beschrieben. Plus natürlich diese ganzen Gerichtsprozesse, die laufen. Dann zwei Texte, Pascal Reinhardt also. Ich hatte es ja angekündigt. Er fragt sich, ob uns die Milliardäre nicht unendlich Leid tun sollten. Und haben wir nicht dieses Appsteam Problem, solange wir Milliardäre haben, einfach weil das strukturell eingeprägt ist. Er gibt eine sehr psychologische Antwort. Also klar, mit Hegel als Anlauf, aber dann vor allem Lacan, das Begehren und so weiter. Ich halte das für sehr schlüssig argumentiert, aber ich denke, es steckt soziologisch noch mehr darin. Also nehme ich das selber wieder als Anlass, um dann später mal drüber zu schreiben. Und die New York Times Vivian Wang fragt sich, wo sind eigentlich in China die AI Doomers? Denn in Amerika fällt das doch jetzt 1 zu 2 aus und die Leute freuen sich gar nicht auf die Zukunft, die mit KI kommen. Und China hat es wohl irgendwie hinbekommen, eine KI Gegenwart zu schaffen, bei der tatsächlich staatliches Vertrauen sich als KI-Vertrauen vererbt. Also ein sehr interessantes Konstrukt. Das natürlich nur mit autokratischen Mitteln und so weiter. Aber es schlägt sich am Ende doch nieder. Und das schauen wir uns kurz an.
Das alles kann man dann hören im Salon. Also der erste Teil mit Bibis und diesen Empfehlungen erscheint dann jetzt sofort. Und der zweite Teil, da sprechen wir ausführlich über Geld als Waffe von Ulrike Herrmann. Das erscheint dann in etwa einer Woche. Ich bin nur noch auf drei Termine kurz hinweisen. Ich bin am 10. 3. in Idar-Oberstein, am 11. 3. in Duisburg und am 26. 3. in Hamburg. Alle genauen Infos stehen auf meiner Homepage.
Idar-Oberstein?
Ja.
Woher kennt man das?
Von den Edelsteinen.
Den Edelsteinen.
Ja.
Das klingt nach Bayern oder so.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, das ist Rheinland-Pfalz.
Rheinland-Pfalz. Na gut.
Es geht um Heimat dort.
Das dachte ich mir. So. Genau so klingt das nämlich.
Ja. Gut. Dann sehen wir uns gleich im Salon mit Bibi. Ja.
Hallo, Wolfgang.
Hallo, Stefan.
Bist du mutig genug, Biancas Buch zu öffnen?
Ich habe große Angst.
Du hast große Angst vor einem Buch, das sich einmischt in ein Metier deiner publizistischen Geschichte.
Und diese Frage, die du mir gerade gestellt hast, steht tatsächlich auf der Klappe drauf. Bist du mutig genug, dieses Buch zu öffnen? Ja, ich hab mit Ole dieses Buch Influencer geschrieben, natürlich auch mit Bezug auf Bibis, also nicht, dass wir sie namentlich erwähnen, das machen wir sowieso in dem ganzen Buch nicht. Aber wir haben natürlich Content von ihr aufgegriffen und haben anhand ihrer Figur uns sehr viel über die Influencerwelt erklären können, ahnten ja noch nicht, dass Bibi dann irgendwann sich eine neue Personality sucht. Aber wir hatten dann schon beschrieben, es gibt auch die Sin-Fluencer, die sagen, Nachhaltigkeit ist mir so wichtig und mein eigenes Ich und Me-Time. Das war ja zu der Zeit, als wir das Influencer-Buch in Deutschland zum Beispiel sehr stark Luisa Dellert. Ich weiß gar nicht, was sie heute macht, ob sie auch immer noch im Influencer-Game ist.
Also die bereitet ihr Comeback vor, oder?
Hat Bibi jetzt dieses Buch vorgelegt. Im Übrigen ist es ja auch so, dass Bibi jetzt nicht nur auf Selbstsuche ist, sondern sie nimmt ja auch jetzt gerade aktuell Teil an der neuen Staffel von RTL Let's Dance. Also so ganz mit dem Rampenlicht ist jetzt hier nicht Schuss. Nein, es ist nur jetzt ein Update beziehungsweise eine neue Variation. Das Buch heißt, wie man Geschichte schreibt, denn dein Leben verändert die Welt.
Ja, ich möchte kurz schildern. Wir sind kurzfristig drauf gekommen, dieses Buch aufzugreifen. Ich habe dann festgestellt und habe es noch nicht so richtig durchdacht, dass dieses Buch wirklich nur als gedruckte Version verfügbar ist. Ich musste also in einen Buchladen gehen und es verschämt kaufen. Ich musste an einer Kasse mein Gesicht zeigen und dieses Buch und offenbaren, dass ich 20 Euro bereit bin zu bezahlen.
Ja, das sind wirklich 20 Euro, die wehtun. Ich habe es online bestellt, um mir diese Schande zu ersparen.
Sehr gut. Es ist trotzdem, finde ich, erklärungsbedürftig, wie ein Verlag diese Entscheidung aktiv trifft. Also kein Hörbuch zu machen. Okay, das kann passieren. Kein E-Book zu machen ist crazy.
Ja, vor allen Dingen für ihr junges Publikum. Ich habe auch nicht begriffen, warum sie das nicht als Hörbuch einliest. Das würde ja bei ihr sicherlich Sinn ergeben, das zu machen. Es ist jedenfalls ja nur ganz analog. Vielleicht will sie uns damit schon etwas sagen. Lass die digitalen Geräte liegen. Konzentrier dich auf das Buch, auf mich und auf dein eigenes.
Ich habe nur eine Hypothese und die ist nicht darunter. Meine Hypothese ist, sie weiß, dass niemand mehr liest und sie möchte aber sichergehen, dass niemand liest. Und der Nimbus, sie hat ein Buch geschrieben, ist auf jeden Fall größer, wenn man das Buch selbst nicht kennt, sondern sich so denkt, wow, dann muss sie ja voll fleißig sein. Sie hat ein Buch geschrieben, das machen ja echt nur ganz wenige. Ja. Also wir haben es hier mit einem Buch zu tun, das nicht gelesen werden will.
Ja.
Aus Gründen, würde ich sagen.
Ich habe noch nicht mal eine Leseprobe gefunden. Ich bin mir gerade unsicher, ob es überhaupt eine Leseprobe gibt.
Ja.
Das würde deine These so jedenfalls stärken.
Das Buch wird hier ganz auf das biografische Artefakt, das Symbol reduziert.
Ja.
Man holt nochmal aus dem Prinzip Buch etwas raus, ohne konkret etwas in ein Buch hineinstecken zu müssen. Ja.
Was ist denn überhaupt das, was sie mit diesem Buch möchte? Es ist schwer zu sagen. Wir sollen uns Bibis neue Welt vorstellen. Wir sollen sie als Menschen erkennen, so wie sie eigentlich ist, sollen darüber aber auch uns selbst erfahren. Es ist so, dass dieses Buch ein Vorwort hat. Überhaupt werden wir mehrmals angesprochen in dem Buch direkt. Du wunderst dich bestimmt gerade, dass du dies und das liest und dann geht es weiter. Hier heißt es jedenfalls, liebe Leserinnen, liebe Leser, das Buch, das du gerade in deinen Händen hältst, ist aus einem inneren Bedürfnis heraus entstanden. Aus der Sehnsucht, mich und das Leben, das ich eine sehr lange Zeit geführt habe, mit einem ehrlicheren, schonungsloseren Blick von außen zu betrachten. Ich habe viele Jahre in einer Welt gelebt, in der Konsum, Status, Selbstoptimierung und äußere Anerkennung an erster Stelle standen. In einer Welt, in die ich mich immer weiter habe hineinziehen lassen, ohne zu hinterfragen, was das alles mit mir machte und wohin es mich eigentlich führte. Dabei fühlte sich das, was nach außen so erfüllend und erfolgreich wirkte, tief in meinem Inneren irgendwann leer, getrieben und entfremdet an. Aber einem gewissen Punkt funktionierte ich nur noch.
Hat sie ein vokes Buch geschrieben? In einer Zeit, in der das nichts erwarten ist, ist sie plötzlich wieder auf dem Trip des guten Lebens, das man propagiert und missioniert?
Naja, vokes, komme ich der falsche Begriff, weil sie da gar nicht unterwegs ist in diesen, also es ist gar kein Kulturkampf. Was ich den Eindruck hatte, ist, dass es ein Buch ist, dass man 2019, 2020 geschrieben hätte, wenn man Sinfluencer ist. Und sie kommt da jetzt einige Jahre später auf den Trichter, weil sie auf der anderen Seite stand. Also für die Leute, die überhaupt fragen, wer ist noch mal diese Bibis? Also Bibis BeautyPalace war einer der ersten ganz erfolgreichen YouTube Kanäle. Gemeinsam dann später mit ihrem Mann Julien Co. hat Bibis ein Influencer-Business hochgezogen, das seinesgleichen sucht. Sie wurde bekannt damit, dass sie shoppen ging bei DM und sonstigen Märkten, H&M, und hat das vor der Kamera ausgepackt. Und dann wurde das immer weiter skaliert. Sie hat dann eigene Produktlinien auf den Markt gebracht, Haarshampoo und Parfums und was es so alles gibt. Sie hat also Fast Fashion vorangetrieben. Sie hat in ihren Insta-Stories tagtäglich irgendwelche Kooperationen gehabt, war also das Gesicht eines Influencertums, dem es gerade nicht darum ging, noch ein bisschen Aktivismus und ein bisschen Nachhaltigkeit oder so etwas zu fördern, sondern sie stand auf der reinen Konsumseite, zeigte dann ihr unendlich großes Haus mit mehr Einbauschränken, als man sich denken kann. Mit dem Privatjet flog man während Corona dann auch mal ins Ferienhaus. Das ist natürlich coronakonform, das im Privatjet zu tun, denn normale Flüge waren ja nicht möglich. Also ein solches Leben führte sie, bis sie dann sich sagte, ich kann nicht mehr, ich will nicht mehr, hat dann…
Bin erschöpft.
Ja, daraus aus dieser Erschöpfung gesagt, ich schreibe mal ein Buch, mit dem sie uns allen helfen will, aus dieser Konsumfalle rauszukommen, wo wir uns natürlich gleich fragen, welche Konsumfalle meint sie jetzt gerade, bei wem?
Das können wir ja natürlich genau beschreiben, denn wem passiert es nicht, dass man in einer Kooperation mit einem ultrafast fashion, die werden doch nicht, oder doch, echte Pelze verschicken. Also kriegt sie einen echten Pelz nach Hause. Ich habe das nur auf Pointe gelesen. Du hast ja gesagt, du hast es von vorn nach hinten durchgelesen. Ich habe ein bisschen geschmökert, ja, aber Zitate, also man braucht nicht lange, um schlagkräftige Zitate auszusuchen. Von daher, sie kriegt also diesen Pelz zugeschickt und ist irritiert, denn ist dafür ein Tier etwa gestorben. Das kann ja gar nicht sein. Tief in meinem Inneren fühlte ich mich unglaublich unwohl damit, die Kooperation mit diesem Online-Händer weiterzuführen. Als alles in mir schrie danach, mich gegen diese Ungerechtigkeit zu wehren und die Zusammenarbeit umgehend zu beenden. Doch warum tat ich es nicht? Ja, sie steckt in einer Zwangslage.
Ja, die Zwangslage ist die, sie ist selbstständig, kann vollkommen frei entscheiden, wie viel Kooperation sie machen will. Sie baut hier ein Szenario der Zwänge auf, wo man sagen könnte, sie hätte ja nach und nach von Kooperationen Abstand nehmen können, wenn ihr das eine lieber ist als das andere. Wir würden jetzt hier auch nicht sitzen und für Kryptowährungen Werbung machen oder würden sagen, ja bitte kauft Pelzmäntel, das ist das Beste. Das heißt, das sind ja alles Dinge, die man sehr frei eigentlich entscheiden kann. Sie tut aber so, als sei sie da vom System gefasst. Es ist nämlich so, meiner Meinung nach leben wir in einer Zeit, in der viele von uns nur funktionieren, ohne sich selbst wirklich zu spüren. Was das eigentlich bedeutet, fragen wir uns die ganze Zeit. Naja, also für allem ist es bei ihr eine Konsumkritik, die sie vornimmt, wo wir aber ja wissen, dass gar nicht so viel konsumiert wird. Wenn man nicht zu den reichsten 10, 15 Prozent gehört in Deutschland, dann kann man nämlich gar nicht viel konsumieren. Wir haben jetzt gerade eine Meldung bekommen vom Statistischen Bundesamt, dass die Reallöhne nun wieder gestiegen sind und damit fast das Niveau von 2019 erreicht haben. Das heißt also, in den Portmanays der normalen Leute, nennen wir sie einmal so, hat sich dieses Dilemma, das Bibi da beschreibt, soll ich noch 17 mal in den Urlaub fahren, brauche ich einen neuen Mercedes oder reicht der Privatjet, nie gestellt. Jetzt kann man sagen, ja, aber wir kaufen vielleicht alle schon mal dummes Zeug und fühlen uns vielleicht dann nur kurzfristig besser und langfristig hilft uns das nicht. Alles gut und schön. Aber sie hat jetzt hier quasi erkannt, wir sind in die Irre geführt worden. Wenn wir beginnen, Verantwortung für unser Denken, unser Fühlen und unser Handeln zu übernehmen, verändert sich nicht nur unser Blick auf uns selbst, sondern auch alles, was uns umgibt. Wir beginnen zu erkennen, dass unser Konsumverhalten nicht nur uns betrifft, sondern eine Vielzahl von Missständen hervorruft. Die Ausbeutung von Tieren, die Zerstörung unserer Umwelt, soziale Ungerechtigkeiten, wo ich aber schon sagen würde, ja soziale Ungerechtigkeiten löst der Konsum nicht unbedingt aus. Man könnte eher dafür sorgen, dass vielleicht mehr Geld vorhanden ist, aber lassen wir das mal so stehen. Allein die Strukturierung dieses Buchs beginnt mit einem Tagebucheintrag. Dieses Buch geht dann dazu über, ein Vorwort zu haben, um dann nach einigen Seiten einen Prolog zu haben. Das heißt, noch mal Vorspiel, Vorspiel, Vorspiel, Vorspiel, man kommt gar nicht zur eigentlichen Sache, um dann bei Kapitel 1 anzukommen. Und dieses Kapitel 1, das spielt nicht irgendwann, sondern das spielt am 27. Mai 2089.
Also ich glaube, dieses Anfangsding kommt auch dadurch, dass man, das wollte ich ja auch noch, wohin, ach egal, ich schreibe es vorne. Und dann kommt so eins zum anderen. Und weil das ist ja die eigentliche Einstiegsbeantrag, dass sie mit diesem Sterbebett-Monologen da und so nur dann ach nee, komm, wir machen noch was davor. Ah, noch, ey, kommt das auch und so. Und dann erfährt man nämlich auch, dass sie diese Zäsur in ihrem Leben spürte, als sie mit Julienco sich gerade drauf freute, dass jetzt das Ferienhaus endlich fertig ist. Und genau in dem Moment verabschiedet sie sich aus diesem Leben. Sie könnten gerade zusammen in das Ferienhaus einziehen. Sie hat sich schon einmal neu erfunden, das steht nicht im Buch, aber das wissen wir ja noch. Ihre Marketingleute haben gesagt, du aber als Mutter 70 Prozent mehr im Umsatz. Und eigentlich hätte sie das machen können, aber sie macht es dann nicht. Und das ist eben der Trick in dem Buch. Das heißt Trick, für sie ist das so der geniale Trick. Aber das Buch markiert ein Ende, der ein neuer Anfang ist. Die neue Bibin.
Die neue Bibin. Die neue Personality.
Also konzeptionell ist es wirklich on point da. Und es ist so genial.
Also das Zukunftsszenario. Sterbebett. Beziehungsweise am Ende des Lebens ist man. Und man resümiert. Sie resümiert. An was erinnert man sich? All die Partys mit den großen Namen. Flüge mit Privatschets und Wellnessressorts auf der ganzen Welt. Besucher auf der Fashion Week oder Rooftop-Lounges. Fünf-Gänge-Menüs in den exklusivsten Restaurants. Es gab keinen Traum, den ich mir nicht erfüllt hatte. Und das war einfach unfassbar schön. Das war Freiheit. Ich konnte tun und lassen, was ich wollte. Kaufen, was ich wollte. Sein, wer ich wollte. Auf eine Art versuchte ich, mein eigenes Kunstwerk zu sein. Für mich aber doch so, dass es von anderen gesehen und bewundert werden sollte. Das war mir wichtig. Wozu sonst hatte ich Unmengen an Geld, Zeit oder Arbeit in mein Äußeres gesteckt und so weiter. So dieses Szenario schildert sie. Nun aber gibt es noch ein zweites Szenario. Das spielt am 16.8.2094. Das zweite Szenario ist nämlich das, dass das gar nicht so wichtig war. Wichtiger ist, sich zu erinnern, dass man die Natur erlebt hat, dass man mit Mitmenschen Zeit verbracht hat, die Natur genossen hat. Mir wird noch einmal bewusst, sagt hier dieser Mensch ganz am Ende des Lebens, wie unfassbar egal es eigentlich immer war, ob ich in meinem WG-Zimmer von der Hand in den Mund gelebt habe oder ein eigenes Haus mit großem Garten und teurem Auto hatte. Denn ein wunderschöner Abend, an dem man sich mit der besten Freundin in endlosen Fantasien und Gesprächen verliert, fühlt sich in einem WG-Zimmer genauso gut an, wie in einem riesigen Haus. Und auch das Gefühl, wenn das eigene Kind Hand in Hand mit dir zum Strand läuft und in dir die schönsten Emotionen wägt, ist bei einem Campingurlaub genauso intensiv, wie bei einer All-Inclusive-Reise mit Aufenthalt in einem Sternenhotel. Ich glaube sogar, dass es rückblickend eine meiner besten Entscheidungen war, dass ich damals in meinem Job auf etwas mehr Geld verzichtet habe, um dadurch endlich die nötige Zeit zu schaffen, um auf mich selbst zu achten und wieder glücklich zu sein. Die nötige Zeit, um all die Momente in meinem Leben mit wirklicher Schönheit und Fülle zu gestalten. Und das hat sich ausgezahlt. Also wir haben hier zwei Szenarien und wir wissen natürlich jetzt schon, welches Szenario das Präferierte ist. Nämlich das, das nicht auf Fashion Week und teure Restaurants aus ist, sondern die zwischenmenschliche Begegnung. Wir haben es hier mit einer Multimillionären zu tun, die sagt, vielleicht habe ich es doch ein bisschen übertrieben. Die jetzt ihrer Leserschaft einredet, also du brauchst kein großes Haus oder so im WG-Zimmer, alles ganz toll und das Kind an der Hand, egal wo du da mit dem Kind stehst, alles ganz egal. Ja, dass du sogar ein bisschen auf Geld verzichtet hast, ist vielleicht sogar noch schöner, hat das Leben noch glücklicher gemacht. Das wird also jetzt hier, man kann es ja wirklich so sagen, dieschen Müller eingetrichtert, dass sie ja nicht auf Ideen kommt. Also wenn Ideologie-Produktion je so transparent stattgefunden hat, dann bitte Meldung, aber hier, das ist ja kaum auszuhalten.
Aber sie versucht immer wieder kleine theoretische Reflektionen. Sobald die kurze Euphorie, die die Anschaffung eines Luxusgegenstands in uns auslöst, wieder abebbt, pendeln wir uns wieder auf einem gewissen Durchschnitt ein. Diesen Effekt nennt man hedonistische Trittmühle. Durchaus solides Konzept, wir kommen nachher bei den Milliardären drauf zurück.
Das geht auf Schopenhauer zurück. Sie hatte in dem Podcast erzählt, dass ihr neuer Freund Schopenhauer liest. Ich glaube, das ist die Übersetzung dieser Lektüre. Gut, ne?
Ja, das ist ganz wichtig auch.
Nachdem wir jetzt diese Sterbeszenarien da oder letzte Worteszenarien bekommen haben und uns schon klar ist, wir sollen das eine präferieren, wobei man auch immer so fragt, zwischenmenschliche Beziehung und etwas Geld zu haben, wäre ja eigentlich der Königsweg da. Also warum das eine das andere ausschließen soll, versteht man nicht so ganz. Jedenfalls, und viele werden es jetzt auch so erlebt haben, da braucht man fast eine Verschnaufpause jetzt, nach solchen hochtrabenden Gedanken. Weshalb das nächste Kapitel dann auch beginnt mit den Worten, puh, ich kann es absolut verstehen, wenn du dich in den beiden ersten Teilen dieses Kapitels beim Lesen emotional mitgenommen fühlst. Sich Gedanken über das Sterben und den eigenen Tod zu machen, kann ganz schön hart sein. Aber mir hat es ehrlich gesagt sehr geholfen, das zu tun. Was, habe ich mich gefragt, ist hier eigentlich als Leserschaft vorgestellt? Also das ist ja für, das Buch wurde ja von jemand geschrieben, wo man fast sagen würde, warum das erste Buch im Leben lesen, wenn man das erste Buch auch schreiben kann. Genau.
Das ist ja genau für das Publikum.
Scheint es ja auch so zu sein, dass man sagt, ich habe jetzt mal kurz das Wort Tod hier angesprochen und wie man sich vielleicht am Lebensende erinnert. Puh, das ist aber ganz schön harter Tobak hier. Ich meine, wenn man irgendein gutes Buch aufschlägt, wird man vermutlich mit Liebe, Tod, Hoffnung, Sehnsüchten konfrontiert werden.
Aber da wundere ich mich eh drüber, dass auf der einen Seite der Buddy-Con von Avengers-Film irgendwie 100.000 Millionen ist. Ja. Und dann greift man zu einem Buch und boah, da geht es jemandem ganz schlecht.
Was?
Und dann, ja.
Da stirbt jemand mit 90 und denkt dann das Leben zurück? Das gibt es auch gar nicht.
Vielleicht hat sie diese Vermutung, dass sie irgendwie... Es kommt immer darauf an, du hast ja auch manchmal so eine kleine Schieflage, die ich dann immer...
Was?
Was, was? Ja, auch ein bisschen amüsiert aufgreife, dass Empirie, das große Feld, nicht aus den Leuten besteht, die uns nach einer Veranstaltung, also sich überhaupt zu einem Besuch durchregen und dann noch uns ansprechen. Das führt ja nicht immer zu dem realistischen Blick auf die Gesamtmenge Podcast-Hörer allgemein, unsere Hörer, wie auch immer.
Ach so, ja.
So und bei Bibi könnte ich mir vorstellen, ich habe das eine oder andere YouTube-Video gesehen, wie diese YouTuber kurz schreiben, wo sie sind und dann ist die Zeil plötzlich voller Leute, weil sie alle Bibi sehen wollen. Dass man da durchaus eine kleine Verwirrung hat und glaubt, man hat es wirklich nur mit 13-Jährigen zu tun, die auch ansonsten immer komplett emotional aufgelöst sind, wenn sie einen sehen, selbst wenn sie das Buch schon in der Hand halten. Ja, und dann werden sie gerade besprechen mit Bibi.
Oh mein Gott, oh mein Gott, ja, aber es ist auch so ein Ausdruck zu einer Hypersensibilität, dass man da zwischen drei Zeilen immer noch mal so eine Triggerwarnung hat. Jetzt kommt aber hier ein ganz, ganz schwieriger Gedanke. Ich kann gut verstehen, wenn du dich gar nicht damit beschäftigen willst. Aber mir hat es geholfen. Aber muss jeder wissen, wie er so meint.
Ja, dann wieder kleine Reflexionen. Theoretische Art möchte ich sagen. Ich habe die Überschrift dieses Kapitels. Also ich bin gut genug, weil ich es mir leisten kann. Da finde ich, das ist ja so neokalvinistisches. Mir geht es gut, also gehöre ich zu den Guten. Ich bin auserwählt von Gott. Und jetzt kommt aber auch ein Entfremdungsargument dazu. Also ich habe die Überschrift dieses Kapitels in einem Ausmaß gelebt und erlebt, dass ich ganze Bücher darüber schreiben könnte, wie sehr mich die darin zum Ausdruck gebrachte Überzeugung zerstört und von meinem selbst entfernt hat. Also nicht nur Produktion, sondern auch Konsum hat einen Entfremdungsmechanismus. Und ich würde jetzt anmerken, nur, also dieses droht besonders bei Konsum, der einfach so passiert, für den man also keine Gegengeldzahlung leistet. Wenn man einfach die Tür aufmacht und da stehen zehn Beutel Klamotten, ja, dann befasst man sich halt mit Kram, mit dem man eigentlich nichts zu tun hat. Und man blende dann auch aus, dass man sich mal fragen könnte, was habe ich eigentlich damit zu tun? Warum sitze ich hier in dem Flugzeug? Keine Ahnung, liegt es an mir? Also wenn man kein Geld mehr ausgibt für Sachen, auch wieder eine Parallele zu den Milliardären, die das nicht verrechnen müssen, das ist einfach Budget, dann finden hier Entfremdungssachen statt. Nur, das sind halt andere Entfremdungssachen, als ihre Leserschaft, ihre Kundschaft hat, weil die müssen einfach Taschengeld ausgeben für den Kram.
Ja, sie geht ja sogar so weit zu sagen dann an einer Stelle, dass sie jetzt, wo sie geläutert ist, vermutlich weniger Geld ausgibt als die Leser dieses Buches. Und da würde ich sagen, das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass das der Fall ist. Es sei denn, es sind Leser dieses Buches, die 20.000 Netto im Monat machen.
Es ist einfach völlig ausgeschlossen. Also es ist wirklich völlig ausgeschlossen.
Sie kauft ein Parfum und hat damit garantiert mehr ausgegeben als der Durchschnitt. Weil der Durchschnitt kauft nicht ein Parfum für 200 Euro. Das ist so verrückt.
Ich frage mich, dass es eher häufiger, wie ein Milliardär oder Zentimillionär, der eine Belegschaft führt, ob er sich wirklich vorstellen kann, selbst wenn er sich ganz viel Mühe gibt, dass jemand von 2.000 Euro im ganzen Monat lebt, statt es einfach zum Frühstück auszugeben. Und ich glaube, das können die nicht mehr. Also es geht einfach nicht mehr. Diese Transferleistung nach unten ist einfach wirklich ausgeschlossen.
Sie schreibt, wenn man sich einmal ansieht, wie die meisten von uns ihr Leben ausrichten, ihre Zeit einteilen und ihre Prioritäten setzen, könnte man meinen, dass wir eigentlich alle den Drang verspüren, uns am Ende unseres Lebens so zu fühlen, wie die imaginäre Verfasserin des ersten Monologes. Für mich ist das ein Paradox und völlig unbegreiflich. So viele Menschen würden ohne zu zögern behaupten, dass Liebe, Freundschaft und Gesundheit viel wichtiger sein als materielle Besitztümer wie das neueste Smartphone oder das luxuriöseste Auto. Ich finde, dass sie da sagt, ja, ich kriege das nicht zusammen. Na ja, wir leben in einer Gesellschaft, in der man seine Arbeitskraft in der Regel verkaufen muss. Also muss man sehen, dass man durchkommt. Dann kann man, wenn man noch Geld über hat, ein bisschen noch konsumieren. Was ist dann der große Widerspruch? Dass sich die Leute nicht sagen, ich bleibe zu Hause, ich gehe in mich, komme in drei Jahren wieder. Ja, weil das nicht geht, weil die die blanke Not, das blanke Geld verdienen müssen, die Miete zahlen müssen, sie dazu treibt, dass sie arbeiten gehen. Also ich weiß gar nicht, wie kann man wirtschaftlich einen solchen Erfolg haben und medial eine solche Cleverness an den Tag legen, wie Bibis und zugleich in gesellschaftlichen Fragen so vollkommen ahnungslos sein. Man kann doch nicht ein Buch schreiben und sich nur mit Konsum zu beschäftigen, ohne einmal darüber zu reden, dass die meisten Leute Geld verdienen müssen. Das wäre ja die Seite. Ich kann ja nicht den Kapitalismus nur in Form von Konsum beschreiben. Es ist ja eigentlich ganz interessant, wenn wir Ökonomen folgen, die denken ja häufig gar nicht über den Konsumenten. Genau.
Ja, vor allem in Deutschland nicht. Gibt ja keine Konsumenten. Wir gehen arbeiten und das war's.
Ja, und sie wiederum geht genau den umgekehrten Weg. Sie sieht nur den Konsumenten und fragt sich, warum kauft er eigentlich so viel? Warum ist der so entfremdet? Naja, frag dich doch lieber mal, warum müssen die Leute eigentlich acht Stunden zur Arbeit gehen, stundenlang noch irgendwo in der Bahn sitzen, um überhaupt da hinzukommen, wo sie hinmüssen? Frag dich doch mal, wie das mit der Kehrarbeit eigentlich geregelt ist. Also es werden ja sehr viele Fragen, die man stellen könnte, wenn man sagt, kann das sein, dass wir so ein bisschen entfremdet sind? Liegt das vielleicht nur daran, dass wir Fast Fashion bestellt haben oder an vielen anderen Dingen? Ist vielleicht Fast Fashion so eine Mini-Kompensation noch mal für das Elend, was man so tagtäglich er tragen muss?
Wir wurden in die Irre geführt, aber darüber weiß sie aufzuklären, Zitat. Werbung, Schule und Medien haben bewusst oder unbewusst, an der Konstruktion eines Menschenbildes mitgewirkt, das den Konsum ins Zentrum stellt. Nicht, weil Menschen schwach oder oberflächlich sind, sondern weil sie gelernt haben, dass Besitz etwas über ihren Wert aussagt.
Tja, das ist so ein bisschen Torstein-Wippeln für Anfänger, um es wöflich auszudrücken.
Aber sie verliert ja auch wirklich Worte über die Influencer. Also Influencer inszenieren ein scheinbar perfektes Leben im Weltesgedacht, in dem Schönheit, Erfolg und Freiheit immer in direkten Verbindungen zu bestimmten Produkten stehen. Die Botschaft ist eindeutig, du kannst sein wie wir und musst dafür nur das kaufen, was wir bewerben. Ja, richtig gelesen. Einen knallharten Satz wie diesen hätte ich niemals wahrhaben wollen, wenn man mich zur Hochzeit meiner Karriere kritisch konfrontiert hätte, denn ich war Teil des Problems.
Das ist ja das Erstaunliche. Wir haben das, glaube ich, fast wortgenau so in unserem Buch stehen. Man kann sich die Identität des Influencers auch zulegen, indem man das kauft, was der Influencer bewirbt. Das ist ja genau der Trick, der da angewandt wird, der ja auch dann häufig funktioniert. Aber dass sie dann sagt, in der Hochphase ihrer Karriere, hätte sie das nicht wahrhaben wollen, dann frage ich mich, wie ahnungslos kann man gegenüber seinem eigenen Erfolg sein? Also das ist ja so interessant. Du hast jetzt eben gesagt, ja, manchmal verwechsel ich unser Publikum mit der Wirklichkeit dort draußen im Allgemeinen oder mit dem Gesamtpublikum, was auch immer. Aber man hat ja, wenn man doch etwas macht, so irgendeiner Art eine Vorstellung davon, der hört jetzt gerade zu. Das muss einem doch klar sein. Und auch was ist der Mechanismus, den man da jetzt gerade hat? Also es würde ja jetzt nicht ein Bäcker auf die Idee kommen und sagen, tja, das habe ich natürlich gar nicht gedacht, dass die Teilchen, die ich hier herstelle, auch esse. Hätte ich das mal vorher gewusst, dann weiß ich gar nicht. Aber was hat sie denn gedacht, was sie da macht? Also das ist ja das Einzige, wofür sie da ist, zu sagen, ich bin hier euer Konsumvorbild, kauft es mir nach, denn ihr wollt so sein wie ich und deswegen duze ich euch, deswegen rede ich mit euch, als sei ich die große Schwester oder sonst wer. Wenn sie das wirklich nicht wusste, dann können wir auch hier mal wieder feststellen, dass also sehr, sehr erfolgreiche Leute im Blindflug durch ihr Spitzengeschäft segeln.
Also hier kommen jetzt auch die billigen Tricks, muss man ehrlich sagen, denn sie stellt jetzt einfach diese Frage, die eben darauf zielt, was du fragst und sagt, wenn wir den Konsum einmal rausnehmen, was bleibt vom eigenen Selbst? Und dann, und da würde ich sagen, das ist dann auch wieder diese neue Perfidie, sie verzichtet dann und schreibt, ich hatte schlagartig alles losgelassen, was mir Halt und Struktur gegeben hatte, alles, was meinem Leben einen Sinn gegeben hatte, alles, was mich ausgemacht hatte, sowohl im privaten als auch im beruflichen Kontext. Und da würde ich sagen, das stimmt genau nicht, denn wir wissen, die große Dramatik in Trennungsgeschichten ist nicht, dass sich Leute trennen, sondern dass sie das ökonomisch nicht bewältigt kriegen und schon in einer Wohnung weiter wohnen bleiben müssen, obwohl sie sich getrennt haben. So, genau das Problem hat sie ja nicht.
Nein.
Und das Puffer, um einfach ein Jahrzehnt gar nichts zu machen und sich immer darauf verlassen zu können, die Leute werden sich erinnern, ist absolut gegeben. Von daher inszeniert sie hier eine persönliche Trennungsgeschichte aus einer Liebesbeziehung, bei der sie durchaus anschließt an Sorgen und Nöte, die normale Leute haben, nur die bei ihr genau nicht gelten. Also sie stolpert wirklich von einer Lebenslüge in die nächste hier.
Ja, das ist so interessant.
Krass.
Aber jetzt so verankert am eigenen Ich, jetzt mal wirklich authentisch. Also jetzt kommt diese Authentizitätslüge, nach der man vorher gesagt hat, ich würde sagen, sie war vorher ehrlicher. Also wer da, mag ja sein, dass da irgendwelche 13-jährige dann gesagt haben, ja, die Bibi ist meine große Schwester. Aber jetzt jeder, der so einen Schritt weiter war, konnte ja wissen, so funktioniert Werbung.
Ja, so funktionieren auch Hollywood-Filme. Wir wissen alle, das ist ein Drehbuch, ein Regisseur, künstliches Licht. Und am Ende weinen alle. Und so ist das sicher auch.
Ja, und ich sehe auch ein tolles Werbeplakat. Dann kann ich mir natürlich kurz sagen, ja, das ist lange inszeniert. Und außerdem sind die da auf dem Bild geliftet und was weiß ich. Aber dann würde ich trotzdem sagen, so ein guter Look gefällt mir. Könnte ich mir auch vorstellen, kauf ich. So funktioniert Werbung. Das aber nicht die Illusionswelt. Die Illusionswelt, die ist jetzt die eigentliche nämlich hier. Sie glaubt nämlich, wenn sie jetzt ein Schleier runterreißt, dann sind wir bei der Wahrheit angekommen. Und dann wird es erst recht verlogen. Sie sagt es dann auch, habe ich meinen Zuschauern Illusion verkauft, ohne dass es mir aktiv bewusst war? Ich denke, dass die Beantwortung dieser Frage stark von der Perspektive abhängt, aus der man auf den Sachverhalt blickt. Mit dem Wissen, was wir heute über Influencer und Werbung haben, wäre es natürlich leicht, die Frage mit Ja zu beantworten. Vorher, also bis vor drei Jahren, hat ja keiner gewusst, wie Werbung funktioniert. Jetzt wissen wir irgendwie, wie Werbung funktioniert. Ich denke aber, dass dabei einige wichtige Faktoren ausgeklammert werden. Denn zu der Zeit, in der ich meinen großen Durchbruch erlebt hatte, gab es dieses Wissen noch nicht. Als ich schlagartig berühmt und erfolgreich wurde, war ich nicht nur enorm jung, sondern gehörte darüber hinaus zu den allerersten Influencerinnen, die eine Millionenreichweite hatte. Für mich bedeutete das, dass es keinerlei Vergleichswerte gab, an denen ich mich hätte orientieren können. Es gab niemanden, zu dem ich hätte aufschauen können.
Ja, also sie verkauft sich hier als Pionierin. Ja. Eines durchaus neuen Geschäftsmodells. Niemand hätte das vorher wissen können, dass es wirklich so durch die Decke geht. Und wir wissen ja heute auch, hat ein Ablaufdatum, also mit diesen ganzen KI generierten Zeug, weil am Ende geht es dann doch nicht so um die Person, sondern Leute sehen einfach auf Plakaten schöne Menschen und das reicht. Es muss gar nicht mehr gezaubert werden. So, sie ist aber gerade keine Pionierin. Sondern sie hat nur ein neues Geschäftsmodell für ein ganz altes soziales Modell. Nämlich die, ich würde es jetzt erweitern, neokalvinistische, also die auch selbst daran glaubt, aristokratische Frau. Anthony Giddens hat dazu sehr interessant geschrieben, ich habe es in der Kinderwüste zitiert. Wir glauben heute immer, die AfD kommt und sagt, ja die Frau gehört doch nach Hause und wie auch immer. Und dann sagt die CDU auch, genau die CDU kommt mit der Hartprämie und der ganze Kram. Und es gab aber immer einen Ausreißer und das ist die aristokratische Frau, von der wir wissen, die hat irgendwie so Geld. Und wenn die nachts 23 Uhr in irgendeiner Bar auftaucht und sich ein Jüngling mitnimmt, dann sagen wir nicht, was ist denn das für eine Schlampe, sondern sagen wir, wow, wir durften heute auch kurz dabei sein, als die große Show abgezogen wurde, so ungefähr. Ja, alle waren begeistert. So, und das ist aber kein neues Prinzip, sondern diese Art von Freiheit, die sie gelebt hat und die sie uns heute als, ich bin geläutert, es war eine Lüge. Nein, sie geht ja einfach nur von einer Freiheit zur nächsten Freiheit. Sie sucht ja nur das nächste Marketingobjekt für sich, um das wieder an ihr Subjekt zu kleben. Und sie ist gerade nicht diese Pionierin, wie sie es beschreibt.
Nein, auch jetzt wieder nicht.
Sie ist einfach in so Kreisen, wo einfach der eine ist halt so Sängerin und spielt vor 10.000 Leuten. Die nächste hat eine Filmkarriere und hat so alle zwei Jahre ein Gig im Kino. Und sie ist halt Influencerin und muss so jede Woche was posten. Aber in diesem Kreis ist das, also da fühlt sie sich zu Hause und das ist genau das Metier. Und so sieht man sie ja auch immer in diesen Abendveranstaltungen, dann schmeißen sie sich alle in so eine Robe und so weiter und so fort. Also sie lebt genau dieses altbekannte, aristokratische und jetzt eben neokalvinistische, sie fühlt sich selbst noch auserwählt und kleistert einfach dieses Pioniersein darüber. Wir wussten es ja nicht besser. So viel Geld, keine Ahnung, was hättet ihr damit gemacht? Also wir haben es einfach ausgegeben und so.
Und das diversifiziert sich immer weiter, bedeutet dann auch, weil du gerade den Roten Teppich erwähnst, dass sie auf irgendeiner Gala zu Gast ist und da kommt sie ungeschminkt auf den Roten Teppich. Womit sie uns dann sagen will, jetzt zeige ich mein ehrliches Gesicht. Nein, das ist auch wiederum die neue Selbstinszenierung, jetzt eben ungeschminkt.
Pamela Anderson.
Ja, sie kommt da ja nicht raus. Also das ist völlig zwecklos, so zu argumentieren, dass man meint, man könnte jetzt, dass ich davon fernhalte, aber zugleich noch ein Geschäft damit machen. Das ist einfach nicht möglich.
Genau, also es gibt ja das Gegenteil von dem, was sie, also sie hat ein Bild von sich selbst, dem sie sich jetzt abschreibt. Was bedeutet, sie müsste sowohl auf den Konsum als auch auf die Öffentlichkeit, die damit kam, verzichten. Was eben hieße, kein materielles Zeug, keine Öffentlichkeit, ja, das ist die Kloster-Schwester. Nur wir sehen sie hier nicht als Kloster-Schwester. Ja. Also die Stringenz, mit der sie das immer wieder hier beschreibt. Also die Zitate sind ja...
Ja, oder sie könnte ja irgendeinen normalen Beruf machen, wenn sie wollte.
Ja, oder so, genau. Man muss sie jetzt gar nicht übertreiben. Wir leben ja alle so ein bisschen zurückgezogen. Aber bei ihr einfach, obwohl ich tief in meinem Inneren wusste, dass mein Lebensstil, blablabla, mich unglücklich macht und dann später, äh, nee, was hatte ich hier noch? Vielleicht versuchte ich unbewusst von meinem Konsumverhalten auf eine gewisse Lehre, ja, darauf zu reagieren und so. Das sind ja wirklich genau diese Narrative, die wirklich nur für die Öffentlichkeit gedacht sind.
Und die auch nur Leute haben, die in der Öffentlichkeit stehen, haben diese Probleme.
Genau. Also, es ist wirklich gebunden an Öffentlichkeit. Und sie tauscht jetzt einfach nur das materielle Fundament, aber es soll natürlich weiter Geld fließen und so weiter, aber sucht man sich halt ein neues Thema. Aber dieser Öffentlichkeitsaspekt, ich meine, es ist ein Buch, das wir hier gerade lesen. Das ist wirklich verrückt. Ja, das sieht das einfach. Dass sie glaubt, man könnte uns mal wieder in einem Buch erzählen, dass das Leben als Schlagerstar so unglaublich war. Das Bühnenlicht ist ja so hell.
Ja, dann lass es sein. Muss man ja nicht machen.
Genau, geh einfach nicht hin.
Ja. Allerdings mischt sie sich auch politisch ein. Wir sind ja politische Menschen.
Den Dienst da hab ich nicht gelesen. Zeig mal.
Oh ja, pass auf, also erstmal was du vielleicht auch gar nicht so denkst, aber jetzt bin ich ja ganz... Und zwar, es ist kein Geheimnis, dass Politik und Wirtschaft in einem sehr engen Zusammenhang zueinander stehen. Obwohl beide auf den ersten Blick voneinander unabhängige Institutionen zu sein scheinen, ist der Einfluss der Wirtschaft auf die Politik oft größer als uns lieb ist. Ich weiß, dass viele Menschen gern die Augen davor verschließen, weil sie der Überzeugung sind, den Entscheidungen der Politik sowieso hilflos ausgeliefert zu sein. Von diesem Hintergrund wirkt es dann möglicherweise wie der leichtere Weg, gar nicht von bestehenden Missständen zu erfahren, anstatt sich mit der Wahrheit quälen zu müssen, oder? Ich bin der Meinung, dass wir bei manchen Dingen ruhig etwas genauer hinsehen sollten. Wir leben in einer Welt, in der Selbstbestimmung gern als ideal verkauft wird. Doch wer wirklich beginnt, diesen Weg zu gehen, der merkt schnell, das System, in dem wir leben, ist nicht auf Freiheit, Individualität und Selbstbestimmung ausgelegt. Ganz im Gegenteil, es basiert auf Wachstum, Macht und Profit. Und ist davon abhängig, dass wir möglichst angepasst und abhängig sind, weil das die Grundlage für ein System ist, das auf den genannten Eckpfeil ansteht. Ein System, das im Wesentlichen auf undurchsichtigen Verbindungen zwischen Politik und Wirtschaft aufbaut, welche diese Zustände zementieren. Ich würde sagen, undurchsichtig sind diese Verbindungen ja nicht. In einer kapitalistischen Wirtschaft gibt es eine kapitalistische Politik, sonst ergibt es keinen Sinn. Und die Individualität endet meistens am Werktor, wenn man die Arbeitskraft verkaufen muss. Die Selbstbestimmung endet immer dann, wenn man noch Geld verdienen muss. Und Freiheit muss man sich leisten können. Welche Hauptpunkte macht sie jetzt aus? Also man könnte jetzt gut über Lohnabhängigkeit sprechen. Wie Zucker, Lobby und Politik zusammenhängen ist ihren Anliegen. Fast Fashion und Arbeitsrecht, da geht vieles nicht zusammen. Und die Autoindustrie hat großen Einfluss, weshalb das mit der Klimapolitik nicht vorangeht. Das ist also ihr Learning. Sie will also hier sagen, wir müssen uns einer Sache bewusst werden. Jetzt kommt nämlich das Dilemma. Ein bewusster Mensch ist ein schlechter Konsument und damit ein gefährlicher Bürger.
Wow, das ist kein schlechter Satz.
Sie wird jetzt also sich ihrer selbst bewusst, weiß darum, dass Politik und Wirtschaft da diese undurchsichtigen Verbindungen eingehen. Indem sie sich dessen bewusst wird, wird sie ein schlechter Konsument.
Schreibt sie wirklich vom gefährlichen Bürger?
Ja, und dann wird man ein gefährlicher Bürger. Ich habe es extra unterstrichen hier.
Das ist nicht schlecht.
Denn man unterminiert ja dann dieses System.
Absolut. Welche Seite ist das?
Seite 73. Da kommt auch sogar das Wort Neoliberalismus vor. Ich fand es nur schade, dass da nicht so ein kleiner Erklärkasten oder so dabei stand.
Der hat dann den Text eingegriffen. Das ist ja wirklich revolutionär.
Ja.
Na gut, also ich habe nicht mehr allzu viel zu diesem Buch zu sagen. Du kannst natürlich jetzt gerne noch...
Naja, diese Hypersensibilität ist schon wunderbar, die man hier nachvollziehen kann. Vielleicht noch so ein kleines Beispiel dafür. Ich habe es nur gemerkt, ich habe richtig Freude gehabt. Wieder eine Ansprache, Kapitel 3 an uns, die wir jetzt schon auf Seite 93 sind. Vielleicht ist dir aufgefallen, dass vieles von dem, dass du bisher gelesen hast, ein negatives Gefühl bei dir auslöst und dich vielleicht sogar ein wenig runtergezogen hat. Möglicherweise hast du manches sogar als so negativ empfunden, dass es dir schwergefallen ist, es überhaupt zu lesen. Falls dem so ist, möchte ich mich als Autorin an dieser Stelle tatsächlich dafür entschuldigen. Mir ist bewusst, dass die Inhalte der ersten Kapitel für einige Menschen schwer zu verdauen sein könnten. Dennoch war es mir unglaublich wichtig, das Buch mit genau diesen Inhalten zu beginnen, denn wir brauchen genau das Grundverständnis und Wissen, das aus diesen Inhalten hervorgeht, damit wir eine Ebene weitergehen und uns von bestehenden Glaubenssätzen lösen können, damit wir Dinge kritischer beäugen und unser Leben aktiver gestalten können, damit wir uns selbst näher kommen können. Aus diesem Grund bin ich auch jedem dankbar, der das Buch bis hierhin gelesen hat und vorhat, meine Worte auch weiterhin auf sich wirken zu lassen. Also diese direkte Ansprache, Liebes, hypersensibles Publikum, jetzt fiel ja sogar noch das Wort Neoliberalismus. Ich weiß, jetzt ist es bei euch schon zappenduster, aber wir müssen noch den einen oder anderen Schritt weitergehen, nur dann kommen wir gemeinsam bei uns selbst an. Und dann haben wir ja schon gehört in dem Podcast, dass sie ja da so Erlebnisse schaffen will und hatte ja da schon eine Fanbegegnung und sagte, jetzt habe ich das so richtig verinnerlicht, was du uns sagen willst. Ich denke, wir müssen da auch uns noch richtig einüben. Jedenfalls geht es schon darum, dass sie uns zum Umdenken bringen will, aber interessanterweise fordert sie dann Selbstbestimmung und Eigenverantwortung. Also sie verlässt gar nicht dieses Paradigma, das Individuum solls lösen, sondern sie sagt einfach nur, nimm dir deine Me-Time und hör auf, irgendwelche Rollen zu spielen. Da habe ich gedacht, das muss doch für dich als Soziologe sehr interessant sein, dass da einfach nochmal so die letzten 120 Jahre soziologische Erkenntnis auf Null gesetzt werden und man einfach sagt, als ich die Entscheidung traf, endlich ein bewussteres, mitfühlendes Leben zu führen, glich mein Leben ein Stück weit einer Art Theaterstück oder Schauspiel. Ich benötigte sehr viel Zeit, darin die verschiedenen Facetten meines Pseudo-Ichs zu erkennen und mein wahres Ich aus dem Schauspiel heraus zu kristallisieren. Das heißt, sie will keine Rolle mehr spielen. Und wo ein Wille ist, da ist ein Weg. Glaub mir, selbst wenn du jeden Tag nur zehn Minuten in dein persönliches Wachstum investierst, wird dich das langfristig weiterbringen.
Also dieses Buch ist ja in diesem Next-Level-Verlag erschienen, in dem offenbar nur noch KI-Bots arbeiten. Das ist ja der Verlag, in dem auch das Haus und Hopf Buch erschien.
Wirklich? Ah, ich hatte überlegt, wo hatte ich das gehört? Ich habe es vergessen zu googeln. Ja, das ist ja wunderbar.
Also jeden Tag ein Schritt.
Investiere in dich selbst, Krypto oder was auch immer.
Das ist wirklich ganz wichtig, in diesem Verlag offenbar und allen dort tätigen Bots, uns in dieser Konsumentenrolle immer wieder neu zu definieren. Immer wieder das Individuum zu betonen. Hier wird jetzt der Konsum in den Mittelpunkt gestellt. Dieses Hossenloff-Hoch richtet sich ja mehr so an die Männer. Also da wird dann so tatkräftig. Konsum scheint mir ja mehr so ein passives Ding. Also ich habe Geld und dafür passieren Sachen.
Ich frage mich auch immer, was machen denn Leute, wenn man dann nicht mehr konsumiert? Also wenn man das dann, nimmt man das Geld dann und wirft es zum Fenster raus, gibt man es an die Armen, verbrennt man es? Was macht man damit?
Nein, du musst alles konsumieren. Am Monatsende ist bitte plus minus null. Und du kannst ja dann feststellen, dass du zu viel Geld ausgegeben hast für Sachen, aber nur für dich nicht zu spenden.
Nur für me-time.
Nur für dich, nur für dich, nur für me-time.
Aber ich habe dich jetzt unterbrochen. Also du glaubst, das ist so ein großes, also das eigentliche Mantra ist da, wir müssen das Konsumenten-Ich immer wieder neu gestalten, möglicherweise auch mal quasi ein bisschen antikonsumistisch, um wieder ein neues Ich-Konsumenten-Ding zu produzieren.
Ja, also das ist ja die eigentliche Zauberkraft des Kapitalismus. Ja. Den Arbeiter zu erfinden, ihn einzubliedern und so weiter. Schön und gut.
Geht über Zwang, nur falls.
Genau, das ist diese normative Seite.
Ja.
Der Konsument muss kognitiv eingefangen werden, weil wir wollen ihm ja die Freiheit lassen, sein Geld für alles auszugeben und plötzlich kaufen alle Labubus. Ja. Das muss man herbeizaubern.
Und dieser Next-Level-Verlag ist so ein Zauberer-Verlag.
Ja.
Er ist sehr gut beobachtet. Ja, wir haben ja im Westen so eine Nachfrageschwäche. Ja, nicht nur in China, sondern auch im Westen können wir das sehen. Und zwar seit den 70er Jahren eigentlich. Und die Werbung muss ja versuchen, eine Nachfrage zu stimulieren. Und eigentlich sind ja diese Bereiche, die Bibi jahrelang bedient hat, vollkommen ausgereizt. Also das gibt es jetzt allein auch durch diese Temu und Schiens und so in einem Ausmaß.
Wir werden jetzt im März Videos gucken, wo man wirklich denkt, was ist das für ein geiler Film, den möchte ich gerne in Länge. Tom Hanks geht als General ins Oval Office, sagt da was Sache ist, der Präsident erhebt sich und usw. Nur das ist dieses KI Zeug, das Neue. Und dieses Influencer Ding so, wir denken ja immer, das ist alles mega Geschichte und so, aber nein, es hat genau eine Jugendgeneration gedauert. Und das ist wirklich Geschichte. Ja, keine Umsätze mehr, keine Protagonisten mehr, keine Karrieren mehr, nichts mehr. Also wirklich heute auf morgen. So 2027 ist es einfach der verglühte Stern, den wir nur noch in Geschichtsbüchern finden.
Dann wird man Erlebnisse bei Bibi kaufen.
Genau. Und dann ist sozusagen, es ist ein bisschen wie in der Oper. Wir gehen nicht in die Oper für den neuen Lippenstift oder irgendwas anderes Materielles. Es sind rein ideelle Sachen, die wir da kaufen.
Ja.
Und die uns, habe ich ja häufiger vorgerechnet, ein Opernbesuch ist für mich mehr wertfinanziell als ein Jahr Spotify. So, das muss man also irgendwie kreieren. Nun geben die sich in der Oper sehr viel Mühe, damit es uns gefällt und es ist wirklich, selbst wenn es schlecht ist, ist es gut. Und für diese Kundschaft hier muss das anders neu aufgebaut werden. Ja. Diese neue ideelle Armengard, was auch immer und so.
Ja, ja, da muss man nicht sagen, einfach länger have fun, sondern wie sie dann hier sagt, lass uns gemeinsam die Welt verändern.
Genau, die Influencer finden sich gerade neu, müssen sich neu erfinden und die müssen ihr Publikum auch neu erfinden. Die werden denen dennächst Sachen verkaufen, von denen wir jetzt noch gar nicht wussten, dass das geht. Wir haben uns jetzt in der männlichen Nachwuchsriegel darüber gewundert, dass sie sich Kostüme kaufen, die aus Pixeln bestehen in irgendeinem Computerspiel. Und dann finden solche historischen Einschläge statt, wie, keine Ahnung, kleines Software-Update, nichts ist mehr was wert. Die Dramen breiten sich aus. Und irgendwie ist es diese Suchtbewegung. Eigentlich müsste man dieses Buch schon nochmal so zeigen.
Positualität, also wir hatten ja schon diese ganze Uro-Geschichte. Das ist etwas, wo die Leute bereit sind, viel Geld auszugeben. Weil ich ja auch natürlich sehe, wie es einen gewissen Postmaterialismus gibt. Also auf dieser Ebene der Konsumgüter, wo man sagt, ja früher hat man sich möglicherweise dann noch das zehnte Paar Schuh gekauft. Oder noch irgendeinen Oberteil dann. Aber das ist etwas, was glaube ich bei einigen zumindest dann nachlässt. Wodurch dann solche anderen Erfahrungen plötzlich wichtiger werden. Wir haben ja sowieso schon diese Idee von der Erlebnisgesellschaft. Das ist Gerhard Schulze. Das ist das Ende der 90er Jahre. Aber das ist noch alles gar nicht durchdekliniert jetzt für diese digitale Welt. Wo man sagt, ja können wir vielleicht auch nochmal Geld damit verdienen, dass jetzt gerade viele sich nach mehr Analogem und nach so einer gewissen Konsumkritik sehnen. Und da bietet sie natürlich alles, was man haben muss, weil sie ja auch, das ist ja immer das Wichtigste, die geläuterte ist. Also man kann ja am allerbesten ein Abnehmenmittel damit bewerben, dass da jemand ist, der mal dick war. Und sagt, wie Harry Weinfurt, ich war der dickste Fernsehmoderator Deutschlands und jetzt trinke ich Slimfast. Das funktioniert ja immer besser. Und sie kann auch sagen, ja, ich habe es einmal durchgespielt. Ich habe alle Fashion-Teile gekauft, die es gibt und bin trotzdem nicht glücklich geworden.
Ja, also den Wandel, den ich hier sehe, also ihr letztes Kapitel, so schreibt man Geschichte. Da möchte sie ja instruktiv werden. Ja. War für mich nochmal interessant, weil hier geht es ja um die Superpower. Wir alle haben eine Superpower. Bisher war ja die Losung, ich, der Influencer, habe eine Superpower. Und wenn ihr euch anzieht wie ich, dann habt ihr diese Superpower auch. Nun ist aber so, dass man einfach zu Alibaba geht und demnächst auch zu Amazon. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie weit die da sind. Und Amazon einfach den eigenen Körper schon zur Verfügung hat. Und ich mir die Klamotte einfach an meinem eigenen Körper statt an Bibis Körper angucke. Ja, weil dann weiß ich auch, wie der Pullover fällt, wie die Brille aussieht, was auch immer. Das bedeutet, diese Vorbildfunktion, das Poster, Posterchild, bin ich selber. Also materiell werde ich selber mein Influencer. Das heißt, die Superpower der Influencer, die alte Superpower, ist da verloren gegangen. Und sie muss jetzt im Publikum neu aufgebaut werden, aber mit einer Redelsführerschaft bei der Influencerin. Weshalb sie jetzt die Superpower formuliert.
Und auch dazu kommt, dass ihre Erkenntnis unsere Erkenntnis wird und wir in ihr uns wiederfinden können. Sie schreibt, ich glaube, ich habe es begriffen. Wow, ich bin unendlich wichtig. Ich bin unglaublich stark und mache einen Unterschied. Und ich möchte den richtigen Unterschied machen. Denn ich bin nicht ohnmächtig. Ich bin unendlich wichtig und mächtig, egal, was das System und die Gesellschaft mir einreden wollen. Ich bin ich und ich kann nur durch meine Existenz positiv in die Welt hinausstrahlen und damit Geschichte schreiben. Ich kann eine Geschichte schreiben, die man auch Generationen nach mir noch wahrnehmen wird. Ich bin nicht nur Gestalter meiner Welt, ich gestalte die Welt, indem ich endlich Verantwortung übernehme. So schreibe ich Geschichte. Und damit fange ich genau jetzt an. Das heißt, hier wird die Idee etabliert, dass man alles in sich verankert, man eine unendliche Wirkmächtigkeit hat, aber im radikalen Individualismus wird das hier getan. Nämlich man sagt ja, egal was Systeme oder Gesellschaft einreden sollen, also du musst, und damit ist sie natürlich sehr nah an Hoss und Hopf und all den anderen dran, das in dir erkennen. Hoss und Hopf würden jetzt sagen, deswegen Krypto und deswegen weiß ich nicht, was investieren.
Die Männer eben ist halt ganz einfach, weil du sagst jetzt einfach, räum dein Zimmer auf.
Räum das Zimmer auf, Krypto anschaffen. Sie sagt jetzt, das machen wir jetzt hier innerlich, die Existenz muss positiv in die Welt hinaus strahlen. Du bist nicht nur Gestalter, sondern du gestaltest die Welt. Wobei auch, dass ja eigentlich eine Drohung ist, dass man also nach Generationen noch wahrnehmen wird, wie sie die Welt gestaltet hat. Also das führt in der Regel zu keinen guten Entwicklungen, außer vielleicht in der Kunst, dass man sagt, ich habe da was für die Ewigkeit geschaffen, aber mit den Impetus heraus schreibt man es vielleicht auch gar nicht oder komponiert es nicht. Jedenfalls hat sie jetzt diese Idee, wir müssen Geschichte schreiben, ohne zu konkretisieren, wie diese Geschichte verlaufen soll. Denn Geschichte schreiben Trump und Netanyahu auch gerade.
Genau.
Ist das jetzt vielleicht auch, die sehen auch, dass sie die Welt gestalten, dass man was tun muss, sich nicht einreden lassen soll von irgendjemandem. Das geht nicht.
Wir sind nicht sehr weit weg von so einem, zum einen Manifestationsgedankenkram, also dass man sich so Sachen ausdenken kann, die dann einfach passieren, die aber dann eben auch radikal durchgesetzt werden müssen. In der männlichen Welt, würde ich sagen, leiden wir alle sehr darunter. Also diese Menusphäre ist im Grunde etabliert, seit sie ihre Wirkmächtigkeit über Gamergate oder was auch immer so auf so einer Idealen, dass sie hier einfach Sachen mitgestalten können. Jetzt der große Kampf, der ja läuft, ist, kriegt man sowas wie die Epstein, das Verhalten der Epstein-Class normalisiert. Ich würde sagen, das ist halt noch offen. Aber es ist halt nie ausgemacht, dass man das für immer verteufelt wird, dass es da so Inseln gibt und dass man seine Töchter verkauft oder was auch immer so, ja. Also es gibt Weltregionen, denen ist das ganz normal. So und hier finde ich bei diesem Buch, wenn sie das jetzt hört, wie wir darüber reden, wird sie so sich wundern und so. Aber das ist halt, wie du es ja immer beschreibst, mit diesen Ideologiearbeiten da drin. Sie versucht, so was Ähnliches für diese weibliche Welt jetzt einfach zu formulieren.
Dabei bleibt sie sich absolut treu. Du hast ja eben schon gesagt, wie verlogen. Das ist jetzt zu sagen, ich bin hier jemand anders geworden, der nun Pionierarbeit leistet bei der Selbsterforschung, was auch immer, sie bleibt sich treu. Sie sagte ja, wir haben es zitiert, dass sie das gar nicht verstehen konnte. Ein Satz wie der, der eigentlich von Influencern die ganze Zeit kam. Du kannst sein wie wir und musst dafür nur kaufen, was wir bewerben. Da hat sie gesagt, das habe ich damals nicht verstanden, aber so war das. Das haben wir Influencer gemacht. Meine Güte, was habe ich da nur getan. Dieses Buch endet mit folgendem Satz. Das Buch, dessen letzte Zeilen du gerade liest, erzählt die Geschichte davon, wie es mir gelungen ist, meinen Käfig zu sprengen und ist gleichzeitig die explizite Einladung an dich, es mir gleich zu tun. Das heißt, das Band zwischen Influencerin und Zuschauerin soll bitte ganz eng bleiben. Nur jetzt gibt es einen neuen Markt, den man erobern kann und dieser neue Markt heißt das eigene Ich.
Ja, und sie würde ich ja zum Beispiel mal mit einem fiktiven Paragraph 129 Redelsführerschaft in einer kriminellen Vereinigung Gedankenverbrechen vorgesicht sehen.
Wir haben jedenfalls jetzt über dieses Buch gesprochen, gehen nun über zu unseren Empfehlungen. Das Ende heißt dieses Buch. Ich zeig dir das mal. Das ist ganz schwarz vorne und hinten. Sehen wir dann die Autorin. Ja, es ist erschienen in einem kleinen Verlag, der hier seinen Sitz in Frankfurt hat. Neue deutsch-französische Jahrbücher, die viel Theorie herausgeben. Wirklich interessanter Verlag, der jetzt also ein Werk von Alenka Zupančič herausbringt. Zupančič ist Philosophin, kommt aus dem Kreis um Slavoj Žižek, beschäftigt sich hier in diesem Buch in mehreren Aufsätzen mit dem Ende. Sie zitiert auch, was jetzt gerade vielfach zitiert wird, diese Zeit der Monster, von denen immer die Rede ist. Gramsci sagt, ja, das Alte stirbt, aber das Neue kann noch nicht zur Welt kommen. Also dann sind wir in der Zeit der Monster angelangt, aber sie geht von dort aus dann schnell weiter und versucht uns, eigentlich zu zeigen, wie Ideologie heute funktioniert. Dabei hilft sie uns mit Begriffen. Sie nimmt zwei Begriffe, einmal Leugnen und Verleugnen. Also die Leugnung und die Verleugnung, da sollte man differenzieren. Sie sagt, in diesem Buch vollziehe ich den Unterschied zwischen Leugnung und Verleugnung. Ihre Strukturen sind grundverschieden, da Verleugnung die Realität niemals direkt abstreitet, sondern sie zunächst anerkennt, indem sie bekennt, dass sie alles darüber weiß, um dann so weiterzumachen wie zuvor. Im Fall der Verleugnung liegt allen offens. Wir wissen sehr wohl und sprechen auch aus, was Sache ist, handeln aber genauso weiter, als wüssten wir nichts davon. Gerade aufgrund dieses Merkmals erscheint die Verleugnung weitaus rationaler und normaler als die verrückten Verschwörungstheorien. Schauen wir aber genauer auf das Ergebnis, so verschwindet der Unterschied beinahe vollkommen. Dann bringt sie ein Beispiel. Den Klimawandel rundweg zu leugnen oder ihn anzuerkennen, um dann genau so weiterzumachen wie bisher, läuft auf dasselbe hinaus. Oder man denke an die Finanzkrise von 2008. Da niemand ihre Realität leugnen konnte, bestand die Reaktion weitgehend darin, zu erklären, dass es nie wieder dazu kommen dürfe. Während zugleich genau jene Strukturen wieder aufgebaut wurden, die diese Krise überhaupt erst hervorgebracht haben. Das heißt, für sie ist es ganz wichtig, diese beiden Ideologien zu erkennen. Wenn ich jetzt nur sage, ja, da leugnet ja jemand den Klimawandel, dann kann ich mich damit erst einmal komfortabel hinsetzen und sagen, und ich gehöre ja zu denen, die den Klimawandel nicht leugnen. Aber verleugne ich vielleicht. Dieser Rahmen nämlich erhält den Glauben aufrecht, dass wir es politisch gesprochen mit einer wirklichen substanziellen Alternative und genuinen Entscheidung zu tun haben, die zu unterschiedlichen Resultaten führt. Dies ist natürlich mitnichten der Fall. In der Politik scheint es, als hätten uns ein makabrer Reigen fest im Griff. Leugnung auf der einen und perverse Verleugnung auf der anderen Seite erscheinen als die zwei einzigen miteinander wetteifenden politischen Optionen. Jede der beiden Seiten nähert sich von den Pathologien der anderen und sie beschäftigen sich vornehmlich miteinander anstatt mit der gesellschaftlichen Realität. Also wir haben das ja erlebt. Es gibt so eine regelrecht Obsession mit Verschwörungstheoretikern, dass wir die ganze Zeit sagen, was denken die denn da jetzt gerade über Corona oder sonst was. Aber das zeigt eigentlich nur, dass man sich mit der Realität nicht beschäftigen muss. So sei es am Ende auch mit Trump. Der sei Monster, aber wirklich im Sinne von eher fetisch zu begreifen. Das heißt, man kann sich die ganze Zeit mit Trump beschäftigen. So kann man verleugnen, zum Beispiel bei der Demokratischen Partei, dass man selbst wenig im Angebot hat. Das Phantasma besteht darin zu glauben, Amerika wäre great again, wenn man Trump los wird. Also auch das ist eine ideologische Verblendung, die da stattfindet. Dabei sieht sie bei Donald Trump eine Fetischisierung der Inkonsistenz, dass man also gerade weil die ganze Zeit Widersprüche produziert werden, man eigentlich eine Identifikation herstellt. Es ist Trumps Markenkern. Heute ist es so, morgen ist es anders. Er sagt das eine und tut das Gegenteil und so weiter und so fort. Aber die Inkonsistenz ist keineswegs eine Schwäche, die von der politischen Opposition aufgedeckt werden muss. Sie ist einer der zentralen Faktoren für ihren Erfolg. Unzählige Male hat sich dies bereits gezeigt. Widersprüche aufzuzeigen, Unwahrheiten zu entlarven oder radikale Positionswechsel nachzuweisen, erweist sich als völlig wirkungslose Angriffstrategie, wenn es um die Art von Politik geht. Was hat nun Alenka Zupančič zu Donald Trump und Charlie Kirk zu sagen? Nun, wir kennen diese Rede, die er hält. Er ist bei Charlie Kirks Beisetzungsfeier. Und dann hören wir erstmal von der Witwe Erika. Charlie hat mit jedem gesprochen. Und wie Jesus Christus hat er allen vergeben. Und Charlie wird auch dem Mann vergeben, der ihn getötet hat. Und dann kommt Donald Trump und sagt, Charlie hasste seine Gegner nicht. Er wollte immer das Beste für sie. In diesem Punkt bin ich mit Charlie nicht einer Meinung. Ich hasse meine Gegner und ich will nicht das Beste für sie. Es tut mir leid Erika. Es tut mir leid, aber ich kann meine Gegner nicht ausstehen. Und dann führt er das immer noch ein bisschen weiter aus. Was hat sie dazu zu sagen? Was hier interessant wird für sie ist, dass natürlich einmal das, was wir alle so diagnostizieren können, zu erkennen ist, der spricht laut aus, was alle denken. Aber es geht noch weiter, sagt sie. Dass der Hass hier so gebührend betont wird, hat auch was Lustvolles. Würden wir unsere Analyse hier abbrechen, er spricht laut aus, was alle denken, würden wir eine entscheidende Ebene seiner Rhetorik übersehen, die für seinen Stil weitaus spezifischer ist. Was Trump laut ausspricht und was andere sich nicht zu sagen trauen, selbst wenn sie es nachempfinden können, ist immer etwas Anstößiges. Etwas, das mit gewaltvollen, verbotenen Emotionen verbunden ist. So wie seine eindringliche Verkündung, Ich hasse meine Gegner. Er verleiht der Gewalt und dem Verbotenen Genießen eine Stimme, dass die verborgene Kehrseite der guten, aufrechten und wahren Ideen bilden, die hier als christlich ausgewiesen werden. Weder leugnet er die Kehrseite, noch tut er so, als gäbe es sie nicht. Ebenso wenig fordert er dazu auf, sie zu übergehen und das gewöhnliche Spiel der Heuchelei zu spielen. Trump geht stattdessen anders vor. Er setzt den Widerspruch in Szene, zeigt dessen ganze Tragweite auf und bietet sich selbst als denjenigen an, der sich dieser Schattenseite annehmen wird. Das ist jetzt das Interessante. Dies ist der Schlüssel zu jener Konstellation, die bei der Gedenkfeier für Charlie Kirk inszeniert wurde. Kirk wurde als Mann christlicher Ideen und Grundsätze dargestellt, als Missionar, wie es bei Trump heißt. Aber wie die wahre Geschichte zeigt, er forderte die Verbreitung und Etablierung der christlichen Herrschaft, auch Kreuzzüge und Kreuzritter, die die Drecksarbeit erledigt haben. Und das sei die eigentliche Botschaft von Trump. Das ist, sagt sie, quasi der Deal, den wir mit Trump eingehen. Ja, wir sind Christen und das Christentum ist ganz wichtig, aber da gibt es diese Drecksarbeit. Und Trump hat die Botschaft, ich mache die für euch. Das tue ich. Und wenn wir Drecksarbeit lesen, dann denken wir natürlich auch an die Szene, in der Friedrich Merz im Fernsehen gefragt wurde, macht der Israel gerade die Drecksarbeit für uns? Darauf kommt sie zu sprechen. Eines der deutlichsten und verstörendsten Darbietungen dieser Logik zeigte sich, als Bundeskanzler Merz erklärte, dass Netanyahu, eine weitere prominente Trampeske Figur, durch die Tötung zehntausender Palästinenserinnen und die Aushungerung und Vertreibung weiterer Menschen die Drecksarbeit für uns alle erledigte. Wenn gleich man sagen muss, Merz bezog das ja auf Netanyahus Anländer gegenüber Iran. Aber sie redet hier von der Drecksarbeit hier in Bezug auf Merz, dass das so ausgesprochen wird, in Bezug auf Netanyahu. Aus dieser Perspektive können wir Europäer in aller Ruhe unser Leben weiterleben, schreibt Zupančič, und uns an unsere kostbaren, edlen Werte hängen. Aber andere machen für uns die Drecksarbeit. Wir delegieren das. Das ist jetzt nur ein Aufsatz, der so ein bisschen zeigt, wie sie denkt, wie ja so ein Genuss gerade darin liegen kann, dass man so tut, als würde man das Gegenteil wollen. Sie hat so einen Aufsatz, da beschäftigt sie sich mit einem literarischen Text. Da geht es um das Aufhören mit dem Rauchen. Und wie sehr man aber genießen kann, das Rauchen dann, wenn man immer sagt sich, dass man aufhören will und das, wenn man nicht mehr aufhören will, der Genuss des Rauchens auch weg ist. Sie schreibt auch über unsere Schwierigkeit, eigentlich den eigenen Tod zu erkennen. Sie bringt da einen wunderbaren Witz von Freud. Sagt ein Mann zu seiner Frau, wenn einer von uns beiden stirbt, übersiedle ich nach Paris. Und wenn wir uns ein bisschen angucken, wie so gesagt wird in der Talkshow, da muss man halt auch mal ein Opfer bringen. Da muss man halt auch mal bereit sein zu kämpfen im Krieg. Da kommt das doch sehr mit. Mit Verschwörungstheorien setzt sie sich an manchen Stellen sehr gut auseinander. Sie geht auch noch mal ein auf den Film, der dir besser gefallen hat als mir, nämlich von Adam McKay, Don't Look Up. Den findet sie sehr, sehr hervorragend. Eine Sache noch, die ich zum Schluss zitiere, weil wir sicherlich auch viele Freunde des Reality-Fansinns hier haben. Sie sagt, das Reality-Fansinns sei also ganz typisch für unsere Zeit. Symptomatisch sind diese Reality-Shows als Unterhaltungsformat. Nichts scheint beruhigender und versichernder zu wirken, als diese übermäßig realistischen Darstellungen zu betrachten und anderen Menschen an realen Schauplätzen dabei zuzusehen, was sie tun, was sie im, in Anführungszeichen, wirklichen Leben tun. Gibt es einen besseren Beweis und eine bessere Veranschaulichung für Lacan's These, dass die Realität immer und notwendigerweise fantasmatisch verfasst ist als die Popularität von Reality-Shows? Die Realität ist fantasmatisch strukturiert und wenn sie zu einem Realen gelangen wollen, müssen sie sich auf ein Kunstgebilde stützen. Das ist es, warum es in der Kunst geht. Hitchcock, Ford, Hawks waren sich dessen wohl auch bewusst. Das heißt, die Reality-Show und ihre Beliebtheit ist Ausdruck einer Realitätsflucht. Wenn man wirklich dem Realen im Lacan-Sinn nachkommen will, dann muss man den Weg über die Kunst gehen.
Ja, ausgedachte Wirklichkeiten. Die Drehbücher kommen manchmal der Realität sehr viel näher als die Abendnachrichten. Sehr gut. Ich finde trotzdem, ich möchte einen Einwand machen. Die neuen Erfolgsprinzipien, wie es Trump schafft, Präsident zu werden, zu beschreiben, finde ich alle sehr gut. Aber sie müssen die Frage mitlaufen lassen, wie sieht das dann im Wechsel aus? Kann man das auf Dauer stellen über die Person hinweg? Ja. Und das scheint hier völlig ausgeschlossen zu sein. Darin liegt dann auch wieder eine Gefahr. Aber ich finde, wenn man so schreibt wie sie, muss das irgendwie so mitlaufen. Weil da ist einfach ein Ablaufdatum. Das Lustprinzip ist da und man kann die Politik dem Lustprinzip unterwerfen, aber das hält weder eine Vorstandsetage in einem Unternehmen, noch ein Interessensverein, noch ein Land aus, so regiert zu werden. Carla Hinrichs, Meine verletzte Generation. Sie hat also ein Buch geschrieben über sich und ihr politisches Engagement. Und es beginnt mit einer sehr instruktiven, also ich hätte es fast vorgelesen, aber es ist eigentlich zu lang und man muss es aber so in diesen zwei Seiten am Stück lesen. Es erinnert an Solo-Album, man wacht morgens auf, es passieren Dinge, aber die Sätze sind zu kurz und so. Und sie schildert diesen Moment als 30 Polizisten ihre Wohnung stürmen. Sie beschreibt genau, was das für eine Wohnung ist. Denn sie hat gar keinen direkten Eingang. Sie wohnt nur in so einem Zimmer und da ist aber noch eine andere Person. Und dann klopfen die an der falschen Tür und so weiter und so fort. Und dann ruft sie ihre Freundin an und dann sind gleich die Anwälte da und so weiter und so fort. Und das führt ja dann auch zu diesen großen Ermittlungen. Aber dass überhaupt 30 Polizisten Durchsuchungsbefehle bekommen. Und sie beschreibt dann auch, wie die formuliert sind, also wie offen die formuliert sind. Dass es einem wirklich Angst und Bange werden kann beim Thema, sollte man sich mit dem Staat anlegen. Und das macht sich hier in diesem Buch durchweg sehr drastisch. Das finde ich auch sehr gut. Dieser Paragraph, der Mafia-Paragraph, der da jetzt, ich würde mal sagen, mobilisiert wird, ein bisschen wie dieser Spionage-Paragraph in Amerika. Dass irgendwelche Leute mit 100 Jahre alten Paragraphen plötzlich aus dem Bett gezerrt werden. Also der hier eben konkret darauf abzielt, organisierte Kriminalität zu bekämpfen. Aber eben aus der Zeit 1848-71, also 1848-71 kommt, da ging es halt konkret darum, den Staat vor solchen Organisationen zu schützen. Dass der Staat ihn selbst anwendet gegen einzelne Leute, die und dann konkret sich auf der Straße festgeklebt haben, ist ein bisschen übertrieben. Und da würde ich sagen, ja, das wurde von ihr völlig zu Recht so aufgeschrieben und ist auch wichtig. Es gibt mehrere Schlüsselszenen, die sie hier beschreibt und die so ein bisschen biografische Herleitungen sind. Zum einen, sie studiert Jura, weil sie relativ früh feststellt, dass die Gerichte und die Gesetze immer erst Anwendung finden, wenn die Katastrophen schon passiert sind. Also, kennen wir ja so Stalking-Situationen. Nein, die Frau muss erst materiell geschädigt werden und dann kann man im Nachhinein da irgendwas machen und dann ist immer alles schon zu spät. Und das greift ja deswegen ihre Wortweih Katastrophe hier auch ein bisschen, kann man ja größer formulieren und sagen, die ganze Klimakatastrophe passiert. Warum kann man hier nicht juristisch einfach einhaken? Warum muss man es politisch machen? Und selbst politisch ist es nicht erfolgsversprechend, aber auf jeden Fall extrem zeitraumt. So, ja, also das, äh, ihr kennt mal ja aus diesen Landsdiskussionen, es ist dann Thomas de Maizière und so eine und fragt, könnt ihr die einfach hier durch die Ortsvereine gehen? Nein, die haben keine fünf Jahre, die sowas kostet. Naja, und sie fragt sich dann, ob sie selber Verantwortung übernehmen soll. Wenn alles auf dem Spiel steht, sollte man dann auch sein eigenes Leben riskieren. Müssen wir uns aufopfern, um diese düste Zukunft, die sie beschreibt klimamäßig, abzuwenden. Und sie beschreibt wirklich sehr drastisch wieder dieser Hungerstreik, rund um die Bundestagswahl 2021 ablief. Olaf Scholz lässt sich dann irgendwann breitschlagen, redet kurz mit denen, sagt, ja, nach der Wahl machen wir einen Termin. War eine Lüge, zu diesem Termin ist es nie gekommen. Aber sie beschreibt hier dieses Schicksal von dem einen Henning, der dann irgendwann von Hungerstreik auf Durststreik umgestiegen ist, nur noch im Rollstuhl rumgefahren werden konnte. Und als er dann nur noch einen Puls von 26 Schlägen hatte, hat man ihn dann direkt auf die Intensivstation geliefert. Also das ist sozusagen die gefühlte Realität von den Leuten, die eine Katastrophe, die sie materiell sehen, einfach selber ausleben. Also auch ein interessanter Bogenschlag und wie sie das schildert. Sie ist aber damals nicht ganz beteiligt bei dem Hungerstreik, sondern wird über Extinction Rebellion so darauf aufmerksam, bevor sie dann die letzte Generation, die es ja mittlerweile auch nicht mehr gibt. Und ihre erste Blockade ist dann im Januar 22. Da ist sie als Pressesprecherin mit dabei. Sie klebt noch nicht selber sich auf die Straße, sondern sie versucht dann, das öffentliche Interesse da abzufangen und rutscht dann darüber aber in diese Szene rein. Dann klebt er dann später auch selbst. Und das sind ja dann die juristischen Verwerfungen. Und sie selber war aber über diese Pressesprecherfunktion immer medial präsent. Weil natürlich dann der ABB kam, Amtschaugespräch zum Thema, ja sie haben sich da festgeklebt, was ist denn da los. Dann eben solche Szenarien, wie sie ist quasi schon verkabelt und kriegt dann mit, ja da ist jemand gestorben, weil ein Krankenwagen offenbar nicht durchkam. Später ergibt sich dann durch Ronen Steinkes Aufarbeitung in der Süddeutschen Line, die Beteiligten des Rettungseinsatzes sagen, also der Vorfall an der anderen Seite der Stadt, dass seine Straße blockiert war, hat jetzt nichts mit unserem Todesfall zu tun und so. Weiß sie allerdings in dem Moment nicht, also geht dann auch so ein mediales Spiel los, dass dann sie auch relativ früh mitkriegt, die Journalisten selbst ergreifen ja plötzlich so Partei. Also es ist auch so ein Gegenwind, den man einfach überall spürt. Sehr interessante Ausführungen hier zum Thema Schmerzgriffe. Es gibt ja für mich, ich hab's ja ein paar mal erzählt, hier in Frankfurt gab's damals bei Blockupy Vorfälle mit Kessel. Also 10 Uhr morgens kommt die Polizei und sagt einfach, es ist schön, dass sie eine Demo machen, wir kesseln sie jetzt mal ein. Und zehn Stunden später liegen die Leute alle mit Sonnenbrand und hungrig da und keiner kriegt eine Toilette zugestanden, es gibt kein Essen und nein, der Kessel wird noch nicht aufgelöst. Bitte bleiben sie hier. So und das sind ja für mich so Sachen, wo ich sage, niemals gehe ich auf eine Demo, weil ich habe gar keinen Bock, abends nicht nach Hause können zu können. So und Schmerzgriffe sind eben so, wie es hier ist.
Deswegen machen die das ja Stefan.
Ja, ich weiß.
Damit du nicht auf die Idee kommst, auf eine Demo zu gehen.
Ja, genau. Deswegen kommen wir gleich zu Anne Wilde und der Frage, kann man irgendwie für alle Beteiligten konstruktiver das machen. Aber diese Schmerzgriffssache, die sie hier beschreibt, wo einfach völlig klar ist, in Hamburg wird nicht weggetragen. In Hamburg sollen die Protestierenden aus eigener Kraft gehen und dann nimmt man ihnen das Handgelenk und biegt das so weit, dass sie schreiend einfach von der Straße geführt werden. Wir wissen ja, in Hamburg ist die Polizei so ein bisschen anders. Das hat ja auch mit Olaf Scholz zu tun und Brechmitteln und so weiter. Also Polizei und ich möchte ausdrücklich sagen, ich kenne einige Polizisten. Eins meiner Geburtstagsgeschenke dieses Jahr, das ich bekomme, ist die Führung durch die Polizei. Ich werde die Kluft tragen dürfen und so weiter. Also alles solche Sachen, ich bin denen schon, das sind schon Freunde und Helfer, aber nicht in diesem Demo. Ich sehe hier im Frankfurter Bahnhofsviertel, wenn hier abends Demos sind, Hundertschaften zusammengezogen werden und plötzlich zähle ich mit 1,92 Meter zu den kleinen Leuten, weil die Polizisten und zwar jeder Einzelne größer ist als ich. Also da findet so anderes Agieren statt.
Das soll schon der Staat sein, der die Samthandenschuhe auszieht und Drogolisse aufbaut.
Ganz genau. Es gab dann später auch Gerichtsurteile zum Thema, also ganz konkrete Schmerzgriffanwendungen waren rechtswidrig, aber das nützt ja gar nichts, sondern das wird dann halt einfach anders verargumentiert. Also sie ist da in der ARD im Mittagsmagazin im November 22 als ein Radfahrerinnenunfall mit Todesfolge der letzten Generation ans Bein gebunden wird. Ronen Steincke schreibt das später auf, dass es gar nicht so war, aber zu diesem Zeitpunkt haben sich Nancy Faeser und Eben, und da wissen wir ja, wie kritisch die Klimaschützer mit der Grünen Partei umgehen. Also HWK, Ricarda Lang haben sich eben negativ dazu geäußert. Und von daher sollte man auch nicht immer glauben, dass da große Bande war. Also wir wissen das natürlich, aber da ist auch kein einheitliches Lager. Dass Dobrindt irgendwann anfängt, von der Klima-RAF zu sprechen und da das Mediale zu vergiften, ist ja völlig klar. Und dann kommt es zu dieser Anne Will Sendung, 20. November 22. Oh, 22 war das schon vier Jahre her oder dreieinhalb. Anne Will ist irgendwie freundlich, lieb. Sie wirkt lieb, als sie da im Vorgespräch auftaucht. Aber die Sendung ist gestaltet wie eine Höhle des Löwen, denn sie sitzt dort mit Marco Buschmann, Joachim Herrmann, Kathrin Göring-Eckardt, auf die man auch nicht gut zu sprechen ist und die Journalistin Petra Pinzla von der Zeit. Zu diesem Zeitpunkt sind schon 13 Menschen in Präventivhaft genommen worden in Bayern. Also diese Gesetze, vor denen alle Angst hatten, wurden da schon angewendet. In der Sendung selbst gibt es natürlich das Dammbruchargument und die falschen Gleichsetzungen, Ablenkungen und so weiter. Vor allem von Marco Buschmann geht sie im Detail durch. Sie beschreibt auch, das finde ich auch sehr gut, wenn man in eine Will-Sendung eingeladen wird, macht man sich vorher Gedanken, was man trägt. Also man macht eine Modenschau zu Hause, Freundinnen sind da und man entscheidet sich für Sachen. Und da muss ich sagen, das ist sehr gut. Das war auch eine Sache bei der FAZ, dass Schirmacher immer darauf Wert legte, liebe Redaktion, wenn sie Einladung im Fernsehen haben, kommen sie doch mal kurz vorher bei mir vorbei. Sie treffen auf ein Millionenpublikum. Das passiert einmal im Leben vielleicht so ungefähr. Das kann man auch mal vorbereiten. Da muss man nicht immer so was aus dem Ärmel schütteln und wirklich cool sein. Von daher finde ich das schon ganz gut, dass sie sich hier mal grundsätzlich darüber schreibt, wie man sich richtig darauf vorbereitet. Und sehr ausführlich macht sie diesen Punkt, also sie sitzt in der Sendung. 38% finden Klibakleben ist scheiße und es wird auch in der Sendung so behandelt und alle thematisieren es entsprechend. Und auf die Frage hin von Anne Will, warum finden sie nicht einen konstruktiven Protest von zivilem Widerstand, bei dem diese 57% sagen würden, wow, das ist mal eine Truppe. Und sie fragt nur, haben sie eine Idee? Ich sehe heute noch Anne Will vor Augen so wie sie, warte mal, Momentchen mal, ich, wieso, nein?
Ich stelle hier noch Fragen.
Genau, ich mache hier nur Fragen und es beschreibt sie sehr gut. Und ich habe mir dann so eine kleine Notiz gemacht, das ist, wir kennen das aus anderen Diskussionen, legale Fluchtwege. Und da kommt auch wieder dein Leugnen und Fairleugnen. Die Bundesregierung sitzt da und sagt, wir haben gar nichts dagegen, dass Leute aus dem Krieg flüchten, aber bitte auf legalen Fluchtlinien. Und man denkt sich so, die gibt es nicht. Punkt. Und so ist das hier auch. Es ist die Definition von Protest, dass es Protest ist. Klar, könnte man jetzt sagen, legt doch einfach die Flotte des Bundestags lahm, klebt euch doch da fest. Nur, ja, am Ende ist es ein Protest auf der Straße und die Straße ist nun mal der am allgemeinsten zugängliche Ort, den wir so haben. Naja, dieses Buch hat jedenfalls einen Höhepunkt, finde ich. Aber sie ist ja auch selbst Juristin, angehende Juristin. Aufgrund eigener juristischer Befangenheit oder Befastheit mit ihrem eigenen Schicksal ruht natürlich gerade ihr Jurastudium. Aber sie geht diese Prozesse durch. Das Amtsgericht Tiergarten möchte im Winter 23 einen Prozess führen wegen der ersten Blockade in Berlin. Das Amtsgericht Frankfurt führt einen Prozess auch 2023. Und das Landgericht München führt also diesen § 129 Prozess, Redelsführerin einer kriminellen Vereinigung. Hier sind wir also auf jeden Fall, wenn es schiefgeht, jahrelang Gefängnisaufenthalt und so. Das ist alles sehr drastisch. Und jetzt Zitate von Richtern. Sie ist also in diesen Prozessen und ab und zu gibt es Revisions oder wie auch immer dieses zweite Instanz dann heißt, wo also das vom ersten nochmal aufgeschlüsselt wird. Es finden Vorurteilungen statt und sie zitiert hier mal Richter. Also der eine Richter sagt hier zu Verhandlungsbeginn, er hält das hier für ganz sinnlose Zeitverschwendung, Zitat. Denn von der Strafbarkeit sei ja wohl jeder überzeugt, alle Beweisanträge, dass es überhaupt eine Klimakrise gibt, also Gefahr droht und hier Protest gerechtfertigt ist, werden abgelehnt. Dann versucht sie es über Wortmeldungen im Gericht zu machen. Sie verteidigt sich so ein bisschen selbst, also sie lässt nicht nur Anwälte für sich sprechen. Nach einem Statement zum Thema, ich möchte den Planeten schützen, fragt der Richter. Kakerlaken auch. Die Dinos sind auch ausgestorben. Die Menschen wird es sowieso treffen. Davon bin ich fest überzeugt. Das lässt sich nicht verhindern. Dafür ist er zu dumm. Also der Mensch an sich.
Von Richtern?
Ja, das sind die Dialoge, die sie als Angeklagte mit den Richtern dann als Antwort bekommen. Sie wird verurteilt. Zwei Monate Haft auf drei Jahre Bewährung plus 60 Stunden gemeinnützige Arbeit. Ein Richter fragt sie zurück, ob sie dagegen wirklich vorgehen will, also der dann das nächste Instanzprozess führt und weist sie darauf hin, dass es auch durchaus sein kann, dass man noch eine Schippe drauflegt. Also dass es hier nicht nur um Entlastung geht, sondern dass es auch mehr sein kann. Sie beschreibt außerhalb, aber eben auch im Rechtswesen, wie der Zahlungsabwickler Elinor komplett beschlagnahmt wird von der Staatsanwaltschaft. Es geht um 800.000 Euro und wir können uns ungefähr vorstellen, ja, ich kenne den Zahlungsdienstleister nicht, aber das ist jemand, dem solche Protestorganisationen vertrauen, dass da ordentlich Zeug abgel- also Geld verwaltet wird. Nur weniger als zehn Prozent dieses Geldes betraf halt den Fall. Ach ja. Stattdessen werden dann einfach alle anderen, also auch Schulklassensportvereine, Fighters for Future verliert plötzlich auch dieses Zugriff auf dieses Geld. Weil einfach durch solche Beschlüsse von Gerichten, dass man das jetzt machen darf, da gar nicht differenzieren. Einfach so Vorschlaghammer.
Also doch Krypto.
Ja, vielleicht doch Krypto.
Ich bin ja auch immer mehr, wo ich diese ganzen De-Banking-Geschichten damit erlebe. Vielleicht muss man es doch nochmal von links neu denken.
Ja, also sie schreibt hier, dass wirklich willkürlich zusammengewürfelte Kreise von Betroffenen einfach in sozusagen Mitleidenschaft gezogen wurden, was besorgniserregend und alarmierend ist. Und sie beschreibt durchaus, die Stigmatisierung und der Chilling-Effekt sind schließlich schon erfolgt. Also das ist ja auch durchaus eine Strategie geben kann. Sie macht dann kurz die Pointe, also wenn die Bauern die Straße blockieren, kommt Christian Lindner dazu und sagt, ihr habt alle recht. Na, das haben wir ja alles gesehen. Also es ist wirklich crazy. Hier beschreibt sie dieses, was ich eben ansprach, die Drohung eines Richters. Er droht mit bösem Erwachen. Wenn sie nicht einfach sagt, nee, dieses, möchte ich Donnie nochmal aufgeschlüsselt haben. Woraufhin sie sagt, und so sage ich oder schreibt, und so sage ich ihm, dass das böse Erwachen schon geschehen ist, dass ich dort hineingeboren wurde, dass nur die ältere Generation krammhaft an der Illusion festhält, als würden sich auch durch irgendwelche noch nicht existierenden technischen Lösungen in Luft auflösen, also der Klimawandel in Luft auflösen. Darauf nimmt sie, sie nimmt auch Bezug damit auf ihren Vater, denn ihr Vater war wohl als Physiker sehr interessiert an solchen Sachen, hat es auch mit dem Klimawandel gesehen und beschrieben sehr viel pro Problem, Bewusstsein von ihm gelernt, aber er war, ist davon überzeugt, dass es technische Lösungen gibt. Also ist auch wieder so eine Verleugnungsstrategie, die mittlerweile, also gerade heute ist ja durchkalkuliert, sag ich mal, akademisch. Aber ja, also in der Ansicht, wir haben es hier doch mit einem sehr, sehr, sehr guten, sehr lesenswerten Buch zu tun, das uns, wie ich finde, nicht nur aktuelle Geschichte mal so minutiös aufschlüsselt, sondern, also mich noch mal ein bisschen mehr davon wegbringt, jetzt mich als Protestierender auf einer Straße mal zu zeigen.
Ja, aber das ist ja gerade das Schlimme daran.
Weil die Gefahren doch sehr hoch sind. Ja, die Frage ist jetzt, wie geht man natürlich trotzdem damit um, gerade es eben nicht fair leugnen zu wollen, sondern was sind hier andere Strategien? Ein Buch zu schreiben darüber und das als Problem aufzumachen, ist auf jeden Fall schon mal richtig und wichtig. Und ich hoffe, dass daraus mehr erwachsen kann.
Ja, weil ich glaube, dass man dem nicht… Also es wird den Ausweg nicht geben. Also ich sehe das ja auch. Ich bin ja auch nicht derjenige, der auf der Straße unterwegs ist. Das ist ja bekannt. Aber ich sehe da tatsächlich ein Dilemma, das so nicht aufzulösen ist, weil das natürlich alles auch mit diese… Wie immer man das genau bewerten will, was da einzelne Kleber, sogenannte Klimakleber gemacht haben oder sie jetzt im Besonderen, es ist ja ganz klar, dass hier in erster Linie ein Exempel statuiert werden soll, das eine ausschralende Wirkung hat, nämlich so wie du sie gerade schilderst, dass Leute gar nicht jetzt auf Ideen kommen, dies oder das zu machen. Ich bin gespannt, jetzt wo die Schülerstreiks in 140 Städten stattgefunden haben, wie das jetzt künftig sein wird, wenn da sich vielleicht noch mehr mobilisiert, was man da erleben wird. Oder wenn es dann wirklich darum geht, dass die Wehrpflicht da ist und manche nicht sich holen lassen wollen. Also ich glaube, dass wir diese Auseinandersetzung, die wir da sehen, glaube ich schon mal recht beispielhaft nehmen können für das, was da noch folgen könnte.
Also dieser aktuelle Prozess, der da läuft. Die Anklage kommt von der bayerischen Zentralstelle Extremismus-Terrorismus. Sie wird als Redelsführerin angeklagt. Es geht um 50 Verhandlungstage. Also ich schreibe dann auch, das ist im Grunde den Hauptberuf, nur dass es halt unendlich Geld kostet. Ja. Und Strafrahmen ab sechs Monaten. Also es ist einfach Diskrutez. Es geht hier um an der Straße kurz für Turbulenzen gesorgt zu haben, indem man sich da festklebt. Absurd.
Wir kommen jetzt zu einem japanischen Debütroman. Er stammt von Hiroko Oyamada. Wir kennen diese Autorin schon durch ihr Buch Das Loch. Diesen Roman hatte ich hier vorgestellt im Salon. Jetzt ist auf Deutsch auch ihr Debütroman erschienen mit dem Titel Die Fabrik. Er handelt von drei Menschen, die in einer Fabrik arbeiten, von der man auch nach Ende der Lektüre nicht sagen kann, was diese Fabrik eigentlich so genau herstellt. Und die, die dort arbeiten, wissen es auch nicht, beziehungsweise sehen auch schleierhaft, welche Tätigkeiten sie da direkt ausüben. Eine Figur, also drei Perspektiven werden uns da abwechselnd immer geschildert. Eine Figur hat die Aufgabe, Texte Korrektur zu lesen. Eine andere Figur hat die Aufgabe, stundenlang Texte zu schreddern. Oft auch die Texte, die da übersetzt und korrigiert wurden. Dann gibt es noch eine dritte Figur, die sich um Mose kümmern soll, die dort im Firmengelände und darüber hinaus sind. Es ist also eine Welt, die irgendwo zwischen Natur und Kultur, Zivilisation und Wildnis existiert. Es ist eine Welt, in der produziert wird für was, für wen. Man weiß es nicht. Man hatte eine Fabrik, die ein so großes Gelände ist, dass man auch dort lebt, dass es dort Restaurants gibt. Es ist vielleicht ein bisschen das Szenario auch, dass da so ein Mikrokosmos entsteht mit ganz eigenen Regeln und Gesetzmäßigkeiten, wie man das kennt, aus das Schloss von Franz Kafka. Beginnen tut der Roman wie folgt. Die Fabrik war grau. Und als ich die Tür im Untergeschoss öffnete, roch es nach Vögeln. Guten Tag, ich habe um 14 Uhr ein Vorstellungsgespräch. Gleich hinter der Tür saß eine nicht mehr ganz junge, dickliche Frau unter einem Schild mit der Aufschrift Druckerei-Anmeldung. Sie nickte, ohne aufzusehen, nahm den Telefonhörer und wählte eine Nummer. Ihr Lippenstift war verschmiert. Der Mitarbeiter ist sofort bei Ihnen, sagte sie. Unmittelbar darauf stand ein Mann mittleren Alters vor mir. Er war offenbar ganz in der Nähe gewesen. Er trug einen Anzug und hatte ein kantiges, dunkelrotes Gesicht. In seinen Händen hielt er den Umschlag mit meinen Bewerbungsunterlagen. Herzlich willkommen der Druckerei. Goto, mein Name. Vielen Dank, dass Sie sich hier bemüht haben, sagte er. Danke für die Einladung, sagte ich. Yoshiko Ushima Yama. Der Mann hatte keinerlei Ausstrahlung. Seine Augen wirkten stumpf. In dem gelblichen Augenweiss schwammen zwei nicht scharf umrissene Puppeln. Ob er getrunken hatte oder wurde man leblos und fade, wenn man sich ins mittlere Management der Fabrik hochgearbeitet hatte? Gleich eine etwas merkwürdige Begegnung und dann verfolgen wir diese Figuren, diese drei Figuren, was sie dort tun. Wir merken auch die Natur breitet sich, obwohl da ja Technik ist, obwohl da so viele Menschen arbeiten, immer mehr aus. Da heißt es, als ich mich zu dem Fund aufmachte, lag da eine tote Nutria vor mir, das Münchsmus auf ihrem Bauch. An den langen dünnen Stielen hingen rote runde Sporenkapseln, das Tiermaß fast zwei Meter. Eigentlich werden Nutrias nicht so groß, oder hatte ich mich getäuscht? Ja, dann fragt sie einen Kollegen, was ist da los? Und er sagt, nein, nein, es ist alles in Ordnung. Die schlafen ja tagsüber. Und wenn man ihnen begegnet, dann ignorieren diese Nutrias einen. Aber, sagt dieser Kollege dann, Sorgen mache ich mir eher wegen der schwarzen Vögel. Sie sehen aus wie Kormorane, gehören aber einer unbekannten Spezies an. Hier leben Tausende davon, am Großen Fluss und auf dem Deich. Das heißt, wie schon in Das Loch haben wir hier einen Realismus, der aber dann ins Magische oder Surreale zu kippen droht. Wir haben also ein Unbehagen mit der Gesellschaft, in der man lebt. Das sagt viel aus über die japanische Gesellschaft, sagt auch viel aus über die Betriebsamkeit im Kapitalismus, wo jeder so vor sich hinwurschtet, etwas zu tun hat. Alle Abläufe funktionieren so einigermaßen. Sobald man aber sich nach dem Sinn fragt, wird es schwierig. So geht es dann auch an einer Stelle, wenn es heißt, ich war nicht bei der Sache, auch wenn es bei meiner stupiden Arbeit keinen großen Unterschied machte, ob ich bei der Sache war oder nicht. So gesehen, schien es verrückt, dass die Fabrik mir so viel Lohn zahlt. Ich hatte das Gefühl, als wären mein Job und ich, die Fabrik und ich, die Gesellschaft und ich, ohne jede Verbindung, als wären wir durch ein hauchdünnes Blatt Papier voneinander getrennt, als würden wir uns berühren und gleichzeitig nicht berühren, als wäre etwas weit weg und zugleich ganz nah. Was mache ich hier überhaupt? Es ist ein Roman in einer sehr luziden Sprache, in einer auch sehr stark von solchen Fragen und Dialogen geprägten Sprache, der von Bullshit-Jobs handelt, der Entfremdung in vielerlei Weise zeigt, der aber, das will ich hier klar dazu sagen, nicht an die erzählerische Qualität des ersten, des zweiten Romans, den wir nur in Deutschland als erstes gelesen haben, also an den Roman Das Loch heranreicht. Vieles bleibt hier so ein bisschen, Versuch habe ich den Eindruck, also auch diese drei Geschichten, die nur ganz lose miteinander verbunden sind, eigentlich so nebeneinander Parallele existieren und so drei Perspektiven auf diese Fabrik geben, das ist noch nicht so ausgereift. Man wartet eigentlich immer da, dass es noch eine weitere Ebene gibt, die man eigentlich erklimmen müsste, um einen großen Roman daraus zu machen. Aber wer vielleicht das Loch gelesen hat und jetzt sagt, ich will mehr von dieser Autorin lesen, kann auch zu die Fabrik greifen.
Solange es Milliardäre gibt, wird es auch Jeffrey Epsteins geben. Das lautet die These und Überschrift von Pascal Reinhardt's Text, den ich sehr gerne gelesen habe. Denn im Grunde, das passiert mir jetzt häufiger, sind die zentralen Gedanken nicht neue. Also, dass man hier mal das Begehren mit reinbringt, wie auch immer. Aber dass es mal ausformuliert wird, bringt dann doch die ein oder anderen kleinen Nuancen mit. Und von daher ist das hier sehr gut. Das Szenario, mit dem ich das mal einführe, ist folgendes. Stell dir vor, Wolfgang, du bist Milliardär. Das bedeutet, pro Tag fällt einfach eine Rendite von 100.000 Euro Netto auf dein Vermögen an. Es gibt nichts, was du dir nicht sofort kaufen kannst. Keine Flugreise, die so weit ist, dass sie so teuer ist, dass sie, du kannst nicht so viel essen, kannst ganze Hotels mieten, einfach. Also alles steht dir zur Verfügung. Und dann hörst du von La Boubous und du fragst dich, was ist das? Ja, das ist ganz faszinierend, ja. So, und das ist ja hier so ein bisschen das Phänomen. La Boubou natürlich als Schiffre. Denn es geht um 2500 Milliardäre weltweit, die fünf Prozent des gesamten Vermögens auf sich vereinen und damit ein Handlungsvermögen haben, das grenzenlos ist. Und genau da sehen wir, und sexuelle Übergriffe gibt es überall, nur das Ausmaß an Struktur, Planung und industriellen Missbrauch eigentlich, das haben wir jetzt nur dort gesehen. Und Pascal schreibt jetzt, na klar, es gibt natürlich den faule Äpfel-Theorie-Ansatz, dass man einfach sagt, ist halt so. Irgendwo sind immer Leute und wenn die dann Handlungsvermögen haben, aber gibt es nicht auch noch generative Mechanismen, die vielleicht greifen. Und darum dreht sich dieser Text. Und zum einen geht er beim System Epstein mit Hegel vor. Denn Hegel, als der große Philosoph des Widerspruchs, hat unter anderem eine Theorie des Pöbels geschrieben, die natürlich nach unten reicht. Also in der materiell unteren Schicht, nachdem man sozusagen materiell ausgedrängt wurde aus der Gesellschaft, akzeptiert man auch die Regeln nicht mehr und sagt, ja, feuerfrei, ich schieße jetzt hier wild um mich, es ist mein Viertel, mir egal, was der Bürgermeister dazu sagt. Und jetzt stellt sich hier die Frage, kann man diesen Ausschluss nach unten auch nach oben beschreiben? Und über diese Milliardärsschicht sagt jetzt Pascal, das geht. So wie man unten herausfällt, kann man oben davon fliegen.
Ja, das ist eine gute Idee, ja.
Ja, finde ich aber sehr gut. Genau, hier Hegel einfach zu mobilisieren und genau das mal aufzugreifen, weil dann hätte man eine materielle und keine moralische Grundlage für weitere Argumentation. Und diese weitere Argumentation geht natürlich mit Lacan einher. Also vor allem Freud, aber er möchte mehr Lacan machen. Kommt natürlich über Bande nochmal auf Zizek zu sprechen, der ja, es kommt dir jetzt sehr bekannt vor, denn du hast es bei Tim Gabel aufgegriffen. Also fünf Tage bevor Pascal seinen Text veröffentlicht hat, hast du es bei Tim Gabel genannt. Dieses Titanic-Phänomen wie Zizek, also ich habe es von dir jetzt direkt auf den Film gemünzt, aber offenbar hat Zizek da auch zugeschrieben, dass man in der Titanic sagt, der Protagonist soll sterben, damit es zu dieser klasseübergreifenden Liebe nicht kommen kann, denn die Gesellschaft hält einen Todesfall aus, aber nicht sowas. Und das hier nochmal zu mobilisieren, finde ich auch sehr gut. Da kam deine Analyse da bei YouTube genau richtig, um das hier von Pascal nochmal aufgreifen zu können. So und dann dieses ganze Grundkonstrukt, also der Pöbel, der nach oben davon fliegt und eine Gesellschaft, die schon große Stränge, um es aufrechtzuerhalten, aber darüber findet halt was statt und da drunter auch. Dass man jetzt diese Theorie des Begehrens überbande, wir haben es ja aus vielen Begriffen häufiger aufgegriffen. Das ganze Silicon Valley ist ja auch fasziniert von dieser Idee. Und wir sehen ja auch, die echten Labubus wurden ja genauso vermarktet. Es gab keinen materiellen Bedarf danach, sondern diese Idee kam in die Welt.
Mit künstlicher Verknappung natürlich immer auch.
Genau, künstliche Verknappung, auch so ein bisschen Exklusivität, Erkennungssymbole, Distinktionsmerkmale, das ganze Zeug. So, Lacan, du kennst dich da besser aus, aber er macht das hier in drei Schritten. Das eine ist der Verlust des Dings. Sobald der Mensch übersprach in die Gesellschaft eintritt, verliert er unwiderruflich das Ding, das Reale. Es entsteht also eine Lücke, die kann man natürlich, mit dem Begriff des Symbols, die Worte, die etwas bezeichnen und so aufgefasst, aber es gibt einen sozusagen reinen Mangel. So wie es einen Unterschied gibt zwischen mir und dem Ding, gibt es immer einen reinen Mangel. Wir werden ja eh als Mangelwesen geboren und aus dieser Logik des Begehrens, die da hier einen Ausgangspunkt nimmt, gibt es kein Entkommen. Niemand entrinnt. Und auch materieller Reichtum ändert daran nichts. Denn die Limitierung, wenn schon nicht das Essen, dann ist zumindest die Magengröße limitiert. Und ich kann pro Nacht auch nur in einem Bett schlafen und so weiter und so fort. Plötzlich ist man so in einer Rotation, morgen ein neues Bett, morgen ein neues Land. Und dann der Mars und der Weltraum. Und das ist ja genauso, wie wir es beobachten. Und jetzt dieser Bogenschlag, Lacans dritte Idee, der hier die des Begehren des anderen. Wenn wir also aus dem Begehren sowieso nicht rauskommen und wir uns über Limitierungen sowieso andere Gedanken machen müssen bei einer Gruppe, die gar keine materielle Limitierung kennt, dann ist eins plus eins gleich zwei. Und wenn dann drei Milliardäre anfangen zu sagen, also meine Labubu ist richtig gut und der andere sagt meine auch und der Vierte so, was ist Labubu? Dann ist ein Begehren plötzlich in der Welt, das es vorher so gar nicht gab. Und es wird dann auch reingedeckt über dieses, die haben Labubus, ich nicht. Was genau das bedeutet, spielt ja noch gar keine Rolle. Noch völlig in der schifferen Theorie und es ist aber trotzdem schon plausibel. Und von daher denke ich mir, ja, das sollte man durchaus mal in diese Richtung so denken.
Du musst noch gerade sagen, wo ist das veröffentlicht?
Bei Substack, wir verlinken es natürlich jetzt bei uns. Aber das ist ein ganz auf eigener Faust. Also ich bin darüber aufmerksam geworden, weil er ein begleitendes Video hatte und dann nur darauf verwies, dass er noch einen Text hat. Und da dachte ich mir so, das Video fand ich sehr gut, eignet sich für den Salon wenig. Aber als Text ist natürlich super, dass wir es hier nachlesen können. Er macht hier einen Punkt, der bei diesem Begehren über dieses Begehren des anderen, wir stellen also fest, dass etwas einen Wert in der Welt hat, den wir noch nicht sehen, weil andere ihn uns schon unterjubeln. Und das wurde ja institutionalisiert. Also dein großes Thema Hollywood. Und jetzt sehen wir ja nicht nur, dass da ein besonderes Begehren, sondern es hat auch eine gewisse Distanz zu, wie man typischerweise ein körperliches Begehren, also wir wissen aus den Romanen und aus Hollywood, nee, also bevor man sich gegenseitig einander ausliefert, kommt erst mal eine Anwarnungsphase. Man verliebt sich vielleicht sogar ineinander. Man teilt einen Weltentwurf und so weiter. Es gibt eigentlich eine Romantik vor diesem, okay, die beiden Körper kommen jetzt einfach zusammen und dann passieren da so Sachen. Und mir ist dann aufgefallen, auch weil das mal in so einem kurzen Video betematisiert wurde, dass Hollywood keine romantischen Komödien mehr produziert. Schon seit Jahrzehnten. Also man muss wirklich weit zurückgehen. Matthew McConaughey war ein sehr junger Mann, als sowas noch on vogue war.
Ja, neunziger Jahre.
Genau, und es gibt keine Romcoms mehr. Ja. Und das ist ein echtes Problem. Ja, du lachst jetzt darüber, aber junge Leute, die heute…
Nein, ich liebe romantische Komödien. Und es gibt leider fast nichts mehr. Es gibt was Aktuelles, was aber sehr um das ökonomische sich geht, wird dich aber bestimmt interessieren. Materialists. Das ist eine Komödie, die ist so gedreht, wie man das in neunziger Jahren gemacht hat. Aber da geht es um die materielle Grundlage. Wie kann ich meinen Look optimieren? Wie kann ich eine Zehn von Zehn werden? Und wie kann ich mit einem Einsatz von Geld vielleicht eine Attraktivität herstellen, die ich sonst nicht habe? Da gibt es das. Aber das ist eine rühmliche Ausnahme. Und sonst ist die romantische Komödie tatsächlich verschwunden weitgehend.
Ja, und das ist durchaus ein Problem. Denn die Menusphäre ist auch deswegen im Blindflug, weil dieses Zimmeraufräumen ist zwar alles schön und gut. Aber wie nochmal genau führt man ein Gespräch, das anbahnen soll? Genauso wenig wie die jungen Frauen verstehen, dass das gerade ein Anbahnungsversuch ist. Also man hat gar keine Codes mehr dafür. Und das führt natürlich schon zu, ich sage jetzt Salopp, Perversionen. So insgesamt. Auch bei der Frage, nicht Milliardäre, die daran nicht beteiligt sind, aber wie denken die darüber, wenn sie das sehen? Also wenn man aus der Romcom-Szene kommt, denkt man sich, Momentchen mal, das ist nicht in Ordnung. Wenn man aus dieser Menusphäre-Szene kommt, wie wir das erleidend und hier auch thematisieren, droht schon, dass der ein oder andere so sagt, ja klar, grab them by the pussy, pussy, so oder? Also das ist einfach so ein salopper neuer Dreh, der reinkommt. Von daher, das ist schon, also wie wir jetzt mit Epstein umgehen, ist sozusagen gesellschaftsprägend jetzt. Nicht nur, weil sie Milliardäre sind, sondern auch, weil es die Frage ist, wie begegnen sich überhaupt Menschen noch? So insgesamt. Dass wir auf jeden Fall an eine Grenze des Begehrens bei Superreichen angekommen sind, sieht man daran, dass Musk und Bezos, nur noch zum Mars und nur noch der Weltall und das Universalgenie und die 50 Mozarts und Trump wird Präsident und als allererstes Grönland. Das sieht man schon. Okay, da sind einfach alle Maßstäbe verloren. Alle Tech-Milliardäre sind komplett durchgedreht. Und ja, vielleicht ist das gar nicht so sonderbar. Also vielleicht wundern sich die Tech-Milliardäre gerade am meisten darüber, dass so, wie das geht nicht. Warum? Also sonst geht auch alles. Wo ist denn hier das Problem? Ach so, es gibt noch die Meinung der armen Leute. Aber die haben wir doch schon längst. Das sind doch die Shrimps. Also in der Ansicht, dass hier...
Ja, diese Skalierung, die ja gelungen ist bei den Vermögen, die ist ja sonst nicht möglich. Wir haben zwar so Longevity-Trends und mag sein, dass man da dem Leben noch drei Jahre mehr abtrotzen kann. Aber das ist ja nichts in dem Vergleich, wie man sich eigentlich von anderen unterscheidet in Form von Vermögen. Es ist ja eben nicht, dass man sagt, ich habe doppelt so viel. Sondern ich habe eine Million Mal so viel. Warum werde ich aber nicht eine Million Mal älter als die anderen, sondern höchstens zwei Jahre bei guter Pflege?
Ja, und so kommt eins zum anderen. Superreiche orientieren sich an Superreichen, weil sie haben ja mit dem normalen Pöbel nichts zu tun. Diese Distinktion ist ja völlig klar. Dadurch findet im, also ich übertreibe jetzt ein bisschen grundsätzlich so eine Entmenschlichung statt, die finde ich schon beginnt, wenn jemand einfach nur noch Personal in Budgets denkt. Also solange man fünf Mitarbeiter hat, haben die alle einen Namen. Aber bei 50 wird es schon schwierig, bei 5000 ist ja völlig klar, die wird nur noch in Prozenten bilanziert und so. Von daher steckt das eh schon drin im Superreichsein, weil man will ja investiert sein, investiert nur in das, was Profit bringt. Und wir wissen ja menschliche Arbeit, Mehrwert und so. Also da müssen Menschen eh anders verrechnet werden. Und das führt eben dazu, dass man diesen Blick dann grundsätzlich, und dann haben wir PdD, Weinstein, Epstein und so, eine Vorbildfunktion haben plus Fetischobjekte mitbringen, in diesem Denken, dass eine große Leerstelle ausfüllt. Ja, also es scheint für sehr viele ein echtes Desiderat zu sein. Und von daher finde ich das alles sehr trifftig. Also wir haben jetzt keine Zaubermaterialien, nichts von dem, was ich nannte, ist neu. Aber man muss es jetzt wirklich mal auf diese Fälle einfach Münzen. Und dann ergibt sich doch so ein Rundumbild, das dann wie bei ihm einfach auf die Frage hinausläuft. Wahrscheinlich ginge es uns allen besser, wenn es keine Milliardäre gäbe, besonders den Milliardären. Um mal eine Schlussbrande mit zu verraten.
In der konservativen Zeitung The Daily Telegraph ist von Akta Makhoy ein Artikel zu lesen, der drei Tage entstanden ist, nachdem Israel und USA beschlossen haben, den Iran anzugreifen. Ich will nur ganz kurz daraus zitieren, eigentlich nur auf ihn verweisen. Denn es wird ja auch gerade so der Eindruck herweg, dass sei das so eine Aktion, die sich einfach gegen ein paar Oberhäupter aus dem Mullah-Regime richtet. Und das war es dann. Aber hier heißt es eben, Millionen Zivilisten sind unter unerbittlichen Bombardements gefangen, während die Vorräte an Lebensmittel und Medikamenten schwinden und die Zahl der Todesopfer steigt. Der iranische rote Halbmond meldete bis Dienstagmorgen 787 Tote in 153 Städten, wobei die Zahl der Opfer weiter steigt. Der Dienstag war der schwerste Tag der US-amerikanischen israelischen Bombardements seit Beginn der Angriffe auf den Iran. Man rechnet, dass fast 200 Kinder getötet wurden. Es werden zivile Gebäude angegriffen oder in Mitleidenschaft gezogen. Es gibt jetzt schon ein Problem mit Medikamenten. Die Krankenhäuser sind teilweise schon jetzt überfüllt. Die Szenen sind die, dass Brandopfer auf dem Boden liegen müssen in Krankenhäusern, weil Betten überfüllt sind. Chirurgen müssen mit Taschenlampenlicht operieren. Einige der Ärzte haben seit drei Tagen das Krankenhaus nicht mehr verlassen. Millionen Menschen sind weiterhin in Teheran gefangen, einer Stadt, die unter anhaltenden Luftangriffen leidet. Wir erinnern uns bei den letzten Angriffen, hatten wir von Donald Trump und von anderen so einen Ratschlag gehört, ja, ihr müsst die Stadt evakuieren, wir greifen bald an. Naja, das ist eben eine Millionen-Stadt, da kann man nicht sagen, geh doch mal schnell raus, in zehn Minuten kommen die, die ist nicht so zu evakuieren. Ja, es ist so, dass der Rote Halbmund angibt, dass mehr als 100.000 Rettungs- und Hilfskräfte im ganzen Land in höchster Alarmbereitschaft sind. Die Hilfe kommt trotzdem häufig zu spät. Zudem ist die Koordination der Hilfskräfte schwierig, weil der Iran eine fast vollständige Internetsperre aufrechterhält, nur vier Prozent der sonst üblichen Kommunikationen kann stattfinden. Das heißt, die Maßnahmen können nicht koordiniert werden. Und so sehen wir, dass also auch ganz erheblich dieser Krieg auf dem Rücken der Zivilbevölkerung stattfindet. Von daher befreit jetzt einfach die Menschen dort auf der Straße. Und die Menschen auf der Straße, die tanzen und sind alle glücklich, dass der Muller weg ist. So einfach geht die Rechnung nicht.
Mein letzter Text für heute. Where are Chinas AI Doomers? Wo sind sie? Dieser Text ist interessant, weil darüber sprachen wir aber noch nicht. Ich hatte es schon vor. Wir machen es dann einfach im März vor Publikum, das zuschauen kann. In der Case kann man ja zuschauen, was wir für Clips gucken. Und dieser Text hier aus der New York Times von Vivian Wang thematisiert eben oder zum Anlass, dass jetzt Seedance 2 veröffentlicht wurde. Also eine KI, die einfach ganze Videoclips herstellt. Und zwar nach Vorbild Hollywood Blockbuster. Da ist ja richtig was los. Du hast bestimmt auch schon Beispiele gesehen. Ja. Das ist ja wirklich nicht ganz ohne. Und in Amerika führt das zu einer großen Angst, nämlich, dass jetzt der große kulturelle Ausverkauf stattfindet. Also Leute, das Szenario, was ich vor Augen habe, ist immer, dass man Oma Erna wirklich Angst macht, damit das der DAX heute minus zwei Prozent hat. Und so scheint es in Amerika zu sein. Also Leute sind wirklich, die sehen einfach, oh Gott, oh Gott und so, während in China Stolz und Aufregung vorherrscht. Leute sind begeistert und verstehen gar nicht, dass man das auch, wie das kann man anders sehen. Also hier ist die New York Times, die eine Journalistin vor Ort beauftragt, ein Stimmungsbild einzuholen, das sie wahrscheinlich der Redaktion angeboten hat. Und während der Text entsteht, wird festgestellt, wie groß eigentlich die Stimmungsunterschiede sind. Wie viel, ja, Eden Musk hat ja schon immer gesagt, das führt alles um, wir haben ja Terminator und so. Und die Chinesen so, nee, ist doch voll geil. Also ich sitze mal, wenn mein Bus kommt und mein Autodisplay zeigt mir an, wie lange die Ampel da vorne noch rot ist. Solche Sachen, die einfach jetzt möglich sind. Und in diesem Anlass aufgegriffen geht es um dieses große Optimismus-Gefälle. Es gibt eine Umfrage in 47 Ländern. In China sagen 69 Prozent KI-Nutzung überwiegt die Risiken, der Nutzen überwiegt die Risiken, während in Amerika nur ein Drittel, 35 Prozent, dem zustimmen. Also zwei Drittel der Menschen sind KI-Pessimisten. Die Kernfrage ist, warum? Und jetzt die Antwort, weil in China KI schon im Alltag so präsent ist. Und zwar in diesen ganzen kleinen Obo-Taxis, Chatbots, Apps da. Wir haben ja vor Jahren schon darüber gelesen, dass in Shenzhen einfach so telefonzellenartige Dinger auf der Straße stehen. Da geht man rein und die 2000 Standarddiagnosen werden ja einfach im Gesicht abgelesen. Und das sind ja alles hohe Trefferquoten und so was geht eben nur mit KI. Und das wird dann einfach da eingebaut. Es ist völlig normal, dass man in ein Restaurant geht, einen QR-Code, einen scannt, ein Menü als Interview dargelegt bekommt. Und nicht als Liste, wo man einfach auswählt, was man essen will, sondern wonach ist dir heute, hier und da. Und dann wird dir halt ein Menü zusammengebaut. Also du wirst quasi sofort inhaltlich bedient, statt dass du einfach irgendetwas benutzt. Also da geht sie so ein paar Sachen durch. Auch im Hotel völlig normal offenbar, dass man im Hotel auf dem Gang ist, und dann kommt so ein kleiner Roboter vorbeigefahren. Und kümmert sich darum, dass alles sauber ist. Also es ist einfach die Omnipräsenz von KI. Während in Amerika die richtig nützliche Seite von KI nicht präsent ist, sondern die ganze Zeit über, morgen haben wir AGI. Ja, wir werden das und jenes und überhaupt und so. Und eine Million Euro und der ganze Kram. Und alle so, ich fühle mich ganz entfremdet. Ich höre das wohl, aber ich kann mir darunter nichts vorstellen. Und in Amerika GPT in der Profi-Version kostet 20 Dollar. Und in China ist das völlig undenkbar. In China ist nicht nur alles kostenlos, sondern auch noch das meiste Open Source und überall verfügbar. Und jede App hat das überall eingebaut. Wir kriegen das hier mit so als, das ist dieser Nerv-Scheiß, das wird da eingebaut, wo es stört, wo man einfach nur was nachgucken will. Plötzlich soll man chatten und so weiter. Das haben die in China ein bisschen anders organisiert. Da wird sehr auf Nützlichkeit wertgelegt. Bloß, es gibt diese ganzen Erzählungen, wie die Landwirtschaft davon profitiert. Man sieht diese Traktoren, wie sie fahrerlos da rumfahren und so. Es wird halt ein bisschen gezeigt. Und es gibt eben neben diesem unternehmerischen Umgang, damit es einfach überall präsent zu machen, aber nicht so den großen Ding, sondern die kleinen Anämlichkeiten, gibt es diesen politischen Dreh, dass wir zum einen hier eine Ausbeutung des Nationalstolz und des neuen Techniklaubens haben. Also die Chinesen haben ja schon gesehen, was ihnen dieser ganze Technikvorsprung so bringt. Und jetzt hat die Regierung selbst großes Interesse daran, diese kleinen Produktivitäts- und Anämlichkeiten im Alltag sichtbar zu machen, zu nutzen. Und das Vertrauen der Regierung, dass man hier schon regulativ eingreift, wenn was schiefgeht, sozusagen wirklich zu entwickeln, während wir sowas ja in Amerika nicht sehen. Schon allein, weil es in Amerika gar keine Gesetzgebung dazu gibt. Social Media 20 Jahre lang stillschweigend. Es gibt kein Urberecht, es gibt kein Datenschutzrecht, es gibt gar nichts so, sondern es ist einfach auch feuerfrei. Also Urberecht gibt es natürlich im Sinne von Schutz von den großen Marken und so, aber eben nicht für die kleinen Leute, die normalen Leute. Und von daher fällt das hier sehr, sehr, sehr weit auseinander, was eben bedeutet, gerade in Sachen Arbeitsplätzen. Also das, was wir zu diskutieren, gibt es da gar nicht als Diskurs. So wie wir schon nicht mehr über Klimawandel reden, sondern die aber überall haben die auch immer den Produktivitätszuwachs und hier wird alles überall eingebaut, während wir in unserer Welt halt so dieses, ne, also da müsstest du schon ein Ereignisgerät mitbringen, auf gar keinen Fall auf Firmenrechnern und ich erlebe es ja hier im Podcast auch. Also wenn Stefan noch einmal einen Text vorliest, bei dem er sagt, den hat er gar nicht gelesen, obwohl es die Pointe war, der Amu Dai, es ist der Anthropik-Chef, der halt einen 30.000-Worttext geschrieben hat, klar, lass ich den Clot lesen, so. Nein, solche Pointe werden gar nicht akzeptiert. Also man muss ja selber durch die Mühle des Lesens, das ist halt in China ganz anders. Ja, also da wäre die Podcast-Anlage so, äh, wie, was, also da lesen welche Texte. Das kann auch die KI, so, äh. Also hier wird es sehr schön aufgeschlüsselt. Was ich halt sehr beeindruckend finde, ist, dass hier wirklich gesagt wird, ganz explizit, es ist das Vertrauen in die Regierung, das hier vererbt wird. Weil Xi öffentlich das zum Thema sagt, macht und sagt, wie hier im englischen Zitat, China must not let AI spiral out of control, gilt das sofort als, ah ja, die kümmern sich. Die Regierung hat nicht nur entwicklungsmäßig ein Interesse daran, das Spiel mitzuspielen, mit Amerika als Konkurrent, sondern auch dieses, was passiert, wenn was ist. Die Regierung kümmert sich darum. Haben wir ja auch thematisiert, wie der Ali-Baba-Chef mal ein paar Monate nicht da ist und so. Ja, also das sei ein anderes Vertrauen in den Zugriff des Staates auf solche Protagonisten.
Gespenstisch.
Ja.
Gespenstisch. Noch ein Text, den ich empfehlen möchte. Nina Scholz hatte vor einigen Monaten einen Artikel geschrieben, wie prekär die Lage für indische Studenten in Deutschland ist. Jetzt hat sie nachgelegt, denn es gibt wieder etwas Neues. Wir haben ja heute schon gesagt, dass es die russischen Studenten in Deutschland schwer haben, dass es überhaupt Bildung in Deutschland schwer hat. Da wird gekürzt, wo es nur geht. Aber wie geht man dann jetzt mit den Studenten aus Indien um? Nun, dieser Text beginnt so. Aditya Mishra sitzt in einem Café an der Friedrichstraße in Berlin-Mitte. Die Dauernjacke zieht er erst gar nicht aus und beginnt aufgeregt zu erzählen. An Weihnachten, am 24. Dezember, erhält dieser Mishra einen Brief. Noch vor zwei Monaten sei er ein normaler Student gewesen. Nun gelte er als ausreisepflichtig. Dabei wirbt das Land Berlin weiter um indische Fachkräfte und Studierende. Im Mittelpunkt von Giffey's Reise, die sie kürzlich unternahm, stand ja auch genau dieses Anliegen. Jetzt soll dieser Mishra und viele, viele weitere ausreisen. Vor einem Jahr hatte er in einer Kleinstadt bei Mumbai eine Anzeige gesehen, dass es da die Möglichkeit gibt, für indische Studenten in Berlin an der Internationalen Hochschule zu studieren. Upgrade heißt, dass Unternehmen so ein Start-up, das das angeboten hat, das zu vermitteln. So hat er dann nach 2024 begonnen mit dem Studium. Er muss dann sich mit jemandem zusammen ein Zimmer teilen in Berlin-Friedrichsheim, zahlt dafür 450 Euro Miete pro Monat. Also Berlin-Friedrichsheim ein Zimmer teilen. Dazu dann Studiengebühren von 500 Euro im Monat und Selbstlebenskosten tragen und natürlich das Sperrkonto. Das braucht er auch. Außerdem noch verschiedene Vermittlungsgebühren für dieses Unternehmen Upgrade. Auch das leistet er dann. Mittlerweile studieren hier mehr als 43.000 Inderinnen und Inder in Deutschland. Und sehr beliebt ist auch eigentlich diese internationale Hochschule. Aber irgendetwas ist eigenartig. Keiner fühlt sich jetzt so richtig zuständig, dass mehreren hundert Studenten gesagt wurde, ihr müsst jetzt ausreisen und zwar sehr bald, in wenigen Wochen sogar. Schon im Februar 2025, erzählt Mishra, hörte er zum ersten Mal von anderen südasiatischen Kommilitonen an der Hochschule, dass sie Probleme mit der Verlängerung ihrer Visa hätten. Es geht dann darum, ob anerkannt wird, dass sie auch wirklich studieren oder ob man das doch einschätzt wie ein Fernstudium, weil möglicherweise manche Dinge auch online zu regeln sind, wo man nicht dann am Campus ist. Und deswegen ist dann suggeriert, dass die aus anderen Gründen wohl sich hier aufhalten und dann den Aufenthaltsstatus verlieren. Da ist ein Rechtsanwalt eingeschaltet, der sich um mehrere Fälle kümmert. Nina Scholz hat dann da und dort nachgefragt, wer dann zuständig ist. Jeder weiß das so von sich. Diese Leute sind überfordert. Manche sind auch schon gegangen, zum Teil ohne Studienabschluss, also einfach nur Zeit verschwendet und wahnsinnig viel Geld. Hier heißt es dann für Wirtschaftssenatorin Giffey steht im März die nächste Reise nach Indien an. Diesmal soll sogar ein Büro in Bengaluru eröffnet werden, um Inderinnen und Inder anzuwerben. Aber was für ein Signal sendet es nach Indien, wenn jetzt eingeschriebene Studierende zu Ausreise aufgefordert werden und auf hohen Kosten sitzen bleiben? Dazu wollte Giffey auf Anfrage nichts sagen. Aktuell ist es wohl so, sagt dieser Student Mishra, dass Studierende in Indien sich gegenseitig davor warnen, bloß kein Studium in Deutschland anzunehmen. Das ist also die Situation. Keiner weiß so ganz genau, welche behördliche Sache zu was führt. Es ist verrückt, aber ja, so geht also der Umgang mit den intellektuellen Ressourcen in Deutschland.
Es gibt einfach eine große Abbruchkante zwischen inhaltlicher, nachvollziehbarer Arbeit und dann irgendwann wird nur noch Politik gemacht in diesen Häusern. Und das ist nicht gut.
Zum Schluss mein Musiktipp. Das Leonkoro Quartet ist ein sensationelles, junges Streichquartett. Ich habe die schon sehr häufig live gehört, kann das nur jedem empfehlen. Habe es, glaube ich, hier auch schon mal irgendwann gesagt. Die haben jetzt ein neues Album veröffentlicht, endlich. Es ist das zweite. Out of Vienna heißt es, mit modernen Werken bzw. ja Werke, die sind 100 Jahre alt, aber du weißt, was dann gemeint ist. Hinter diesen Werken steht eigentlich Arnold Schönberg als der Gründervater dieser neuen Musik, der Zwölftonmusik. Allerdings ist es jetzt nicht einfach die Zwölftonmusik, wie man sie sich vielleicht als erstes jetzt denkt, als Klischee. Das ist also so ganz mechanisch, mathematisch. Wo ist denn das Gefühl oder so? Nein, nein, es ist beides. Es basiert auf dem Arttonalen. Es ist jetzt nicht alles Schönberg einfach umgesetzt, sondern eigene Wege werden gegangen. Aber wir werden, wenn man diese Platte sich anhört, merken, wie lyrisch, zart, wie melodiös das denn noch sein kann, wie sehr das Gefühlvolle eine Rolle spielt. Und das ist auch dem Leonkoro Quartet zu verdanken, dass sie höchste Präzision an den Tag legen, dass sie dabei aber nie ins mechanische oder mathematische einfach abgleiten, sondern zeigen auch, woher diese Musik stammt. Denn die Idee bei Schönberg ist ja durchaus zu sagen, die Romantik ist jetzt mit der Spätromantik am Ende angekommen. Wir müssen jetzt ein neues System wieder kreieren, weil sonst nichts mehr Zwingendes da ist. Was man aber braucht, man braucht eine Form, in der man sich dann ausdrücken kann. Aber natürlich ist das quasi eine Entwicklung aus dem neunzehnten Jahrhundert heraus, weshalb in den gerade frühen Kompositionen auch das neunzehnte Jahrhundert mitklinkt oder beziehungsweise kann man eine Atmosphäre herstellen, in der man auch das neunzehnte Jahrhundert noch spüren kann. Aber ganz neue Wege werden beschritten. Gespielt wird die Lyrische Suite von Alban Berg, dann Five Pieces for String Quartet von Erwin Schulhoff, ein Komponist, der wieder entdeckt wurde, aber sicherlich noch nicht hinreichend entdeckt wurde. Und ein Komponist, den ich besonders mag, Anton Weber. Da werden die Five Movements for String Quartet gespielt. Und der berühmte Langsame Satz, der einen wirklich auch nochmal einhüllt, bei allem, was er auch atonal zu bieten kann, wie wir dann nochmal mitgerissen werden. Es ist hervorragend, wie heftig innerlich bewegt man sein kann, wenn man diese Musik hört, wie facettenreich das ist. Man muss überhaupt keine Angst haben vor dieser Musik. Man muss also nicht im 19. Jahrhundert immer nur stecken und das nicht verlassen, sondern wenn man so einen wirklich sehr, sehr feinen, präzisen und sinnlichen Zugriff auf diese Werke pflegt, wie das Leonkoro Quartet das tut, dann wird man begeistert sein, von einer solchen Musik, will mehr davon hören. Es ist wirklich ein herausragend gutes Album, fantastisch aufgenommen und ich bin mir sicher, dass alle eigentlich ihre Freude mit diesem Werk haben können, mit diesem Album haben können, weil es so vielschichtig ist. Da ist auch bei Erwin Schulhoff zum Beispiel der Tango und die Tarantella, der Walzer, all das ist auch dort zu vernehmen. Das ist das Besondere. Das ist eben nicht einfach ein Bruch, es ist nicht Stunden Null in der Musikgeschichte, sondern es ist ein Weiterdenken. Wir merken, wie Anton Weber uns innere Zustände musikalisch transparent macht, wie wir da mitfühlen können. Bei Alban Berg sind wir eigentlich auf den Spuren der großen Streichquartette des 19. Jahrhunderts. Und wir sehen dann, welche Richtung man einschlagen kann. Nicht kappt man damit die Vergangenheit, sondern man geht wirklich den Schritt in die Zukunft. Ich bin sehr begeistert davon, kann das nur jedem ans Herz legen, das zu hören. Und wir werden ja auch bald einen Streichquartett besuchen, hier in Frankfurt. Ich bin dann sehr gespannt, was du dazu sagst, denn das ist ja ein ganz besonderes, intensives Musikerlebnis überhaupt noch mal hier. Der Hinweis nicht nur für das Leonkoro Quartet gültig, sondern generell, wenn man irgendwo die Gelegenheit hat, einen Abend mit einem Streichquartett zu hören, unbedingt das mal erleben, wie großartig das ist, wenn vier Menschen aufeinander eingespielt sind und durch die Instrumente miteinander kommunizieren, zanken, schreien, leiden, schreien und lachen.
Ich gestatte mir diese kleine Pointe.
Du darfst jetzt aber nicht antrioriös sagen.
Nein, wir waren in einer Oper mit dieser Art modernen Musik. Ja. Sie hieß Blühen. Wir haben seltenerweise wahrscheinlich der einzige Einführungsvortrag mal gesehen. Der endete nach 20 Minuten mit den Worten. Jetzt habe ich Ihnen das alles beschrieben, aber Sie werden nichts davon hören. Viel Spaß.
Das mag sein, weil dort sehr viele musikalische, musikwissenschaftliche Erläuterungen folgten. Das, was ich jetzt so impressionistisch sagen würde, das wird man nachvollziehen können. Ich bin mir ganz sicher.
Sehr gut. Gut.
Dann sehen wir uns bzw. hören uns für den Live-Salon wieder und für Ulrike Herrmann. Da kommt ja noch die Folge dann in einer Woche. Wir sprechen über Geld als Waffe.
Genau so.